bien monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la séance est reprise nous
reprenons la discussion du projet de loi
pour contrôler l'immigration améliorer
l'intégration dans la discussion des
articles nous avons achevé les prises de
parole sur l'article 3 et nous sommes
parvenus aux amendements 655 à 530
tendant à supprimer l'article 3
je suis saisi de 4 amendements
identiques de
suppression la parole est à madame le
rapporteur pour présenter l'amendement
655 merci monsieur le Président alors
quelques mots d'explication sur cet
article de suppression de l'article 3
qui évidemment nous engage à revenir à
ce qu'est l'article 3 pour pouvoir en
expliquer les
raisons partons de de de fait que tout
le monde connaît qui est qu'il existe
dans ce pays des employeurs qui de façon
irrégulière emploie des étrangers qui ne
possédant pas d'autorisation de travail
travaill aussi de façon
irrégulière je mets ces irrégularités
dos à dos même si nous pouvons discuter
de la responsabilité des uns et des
autres en tout cas la réalité est que
tout le monde trahit la loi et que nous
législateurs nous ne pouvons que partir
du Pr principe que nous ne pouvons nous
résigner à ce que la loi soit en
permanence bafouée donc la première
position me semble-t-il que nous devons
avoir est de ne pas accepter et se
résigner sur cette situation qui
consiste pour chacun à ne pas respecter
la loi s'agissantant de l'employeur que
du salarié pour autant une fois que nous
avons affirmé cette position de principe
nous savons tous aussi parce que nous
sommes à peu près tous des élus locaux
que nous avons diriger des exécutifs ou
pas mais que nous connaissons la réalité
du terrain que la réalité est souvent
plus complexe que la sèche application
de la loi et c'est pourquoi en matière
de droits des étrangers et de séjours
irrégulier il existe un dispositif qui
s'appelle l'admission exceptionnelle au
séjour qui permet de façon
exceptionnelle comme il indique de
régulariser la situation de quelqu'un
qui par définition n'est pas en
situation régulière ce dispositif il est
l'application en droit des étrangers
d'un principe général de droit
administratif qui est la capacité pour
chacun c'est-à-dire pour un étranger
comme pour un pour un Français qui
habite sur le territoire français de
solliciter de
l'administration une révision de sa
situation individuelle et
l'administration peut parfaitement dans
ces conditions admettre que la personne
qui sollicite la révision de sa
situation puisse bénéficier d'un droit
auquel elle n'a pas droit si l'on se
réfère à la à la pure application du
texte l'admission exceptionnelle au
séjour ça consiste pour le préfet à
vérifier effectivement que au regard de
l'irrégularité mais au regard aussi de
la situation de l'étranger et bien
celui-ci peut se voir ou va se voir
délivrer un titre de séjour nous savons
tous ce qu'est la circulaire Vals la
circulaire Vals ce sont les orientations
général qui permettent pour les préfets
de se guider dans cette admission
exceptionnelle au séjour on l'a si on l'
préçuit pas suivant les bandes de cet
hémicycle mais ce sont des orientations
générales qui d'ailleurs permettent de
régulariser plus souvent par le droit de
la famille si je puis dire que pour le
travail mais elle existe aussi pour le
travail là-dessus je ne fais que
rappeler le droit positif ce droit
positif aucun de nous n'a voulu le
modifier et nous admettons tous je crois
dans cet hémicycle ou presque qu'il
existe cette admission exceptionnelle au
séjour l'article 3 qui avait
été introduit dans le projet de loi par
le gouvernement visait également à une
régularisation de travailleurs
irrégulierers dans une situation un peu
particulière qui est celle des métiers
en tenstion mais cet article avait
procédé juridiquement tout à fait
différemment puisqu'il s'agissait pour
les travailleurs qui étaient en
situation
irrégulière de fournir la preuve de leur
activité une activité sur un certain
nombre de mois après un certain nombre
d'années de présence sur le territoire
français et que cette preuve étant
fournie par tout moyen sans l'aide de
l'employeur et bien
automatiquement cette euh ce travailleur
en situation irrégulière serait
régularisé nous ne l'avons pas accepté
ça chacun a entendu parler de l'article
3 dans cet hémicycle bien évidemment
mais même en dehors pourquoi nous ne
l'avons pas accepté parce que nous
sortions de la casuistique de
l'admission exceptionnelle au séjour qui
par définition nécessitait de regarder
extrêmement précisément quelle était la
situation de chacun nous sortions de
l'admission exceptionnelle de séjour et
l'application de cette régularisation de
droit entraîit la régularisation
automatique sans que l'État par
l'intermédière du préfet ne fasse plus
usage de son pouvoir discrétionnaire
cette régularisation était donc
automatique l'État se départissait de
son droit sur un domaine aussi régalien
qui le droit des étrangers l'État se
départissait de son droit et de surcroix
le mécanisme induisit qu'automatiquement
en faisant la preuve de la fraude un
droit a été créé nous l'avons longuement
débattu il a un principe de droit que
chacun connaît ici la fraude corront
tout la fraude devenait créatice de
droit nous étions très en dehors nous
semblait-il de de la réalité de ce que
devait être le droit et le législateur
ne pouvait pas à notre sens créer une
disposition qui
faisait qui faisait juridiquement qui
créait un un droit uniquement basé sur
la preuve de la fraude pour peu qu'elle
fut suffisamment longue et habile en
conséquence de quoi nous n'avons pas
souhaité maintenir ce
dispositif c'est pourquoi nous avons
sollicité la suppression de cet article
3 cela a été expliqué tout à l'heure je
ne vais pas expliquer le prochain
article au bénéfice d'une autre
disposition qui
revient au premier dispositif à celui
qui existe encore une fois que personne
n voulu modifier de l'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour qui rétablit
l'État dans son pouvoir égalien et qui
rétablit un examen casustique au cas par
cas de chacune des situations qui sera
déposée auprès du préfet et qu'il pourra
examiner de cette façon donc voilà d'une
façon que j'espère assez factuelle les
raisons pour lesquelles l'article 3 a
été supprimé ou va être supprimé par
notre assemblée après qu'un avis
favorable a été donné par la
commission merci madame le rapporteur je
propose à Monsieur zureg de présenter
son amendement
126 mon cher collègue vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
en raison de la présence en France de
près de 4 millions et demi de
travailleurs immigrés et de membres de
leur famille la poursuite de
l'immigration pose aujourd'hui de graves
problème il faut stopper l'immigration
officielle et clandestine nous pensons
que tous les travailleurs son frère
indépendamment du pays où ils sont nés
mais dans la crise actuelle
l'immigration constitue pour les patrons
et le gouvernement un moyen d'aggraver
le chômage les bas salaires les
mauvaises conditions de travail la
répression contre tous les travailleurs
aussi bien immigrés que français c'est
pourquoi nous disons il faut arrêter
l'immigration sous peine de jeter de
nouveaux travailleurs au chômage ces
mots ne sont pas ceux de Marine Le Pen
mais ceux de George March en 19801
raison pour laquelle nous maintenons
notre souhait de supprimer cet article 3
je vous
remercie merci je propose à Monsieur
Dufour de présenter l'amendement
366 vous avez la parole monsieur Dufour
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur mes chers collègues j'ai
présenté cet amendement de de
suppression et c'est vrai que des
collègues m'ont dit que c'était un peu
singulier un peu marginal mais je
m'aperçois que à la lecture de ce qui a
été fait il y a quelques instants
quelques heures il y aura un amendement
en définitive
qui sera substitué à à l'article 3 et
permettra d'obtenir un compromis entre
les diverses formations politiques alors
pourquoi j'ai présenté cet amendement
parce que sur le texte où on veut
réguler l'immigration je m'aperçois en
définitive qu'on veut faire faire venir
des étrangers et les régularisé dans des
métiers d' intention donc cela me paraît
tout à fait contraire et contradictoire
par ailleurs la loi qui a été votée sur
le chômage indique que que les personnes
qui refuseront un contrat durée
indéterminé après deux contrats qu'elles
auront déjà essayé seront privés de des
droits au chômage alors quand nous
savons qu'en France il y a plus de 5
millions de chômeurs je vois pas
pourquoi aujourd'hui on inciterait des
étrangers à venir travailler dans des
mitiers d' antention voilà pourquoi
Monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
je souhaitais proposer cet article et je
me prononcerai bien entendu sur la
nouvelle rédaction plus tard très bien
mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur ravier pour l'amend
530 merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues l'article 3 en même
temps que le grand emplacement c'est le
grand renoncement la nouvelle carte de
séjour métier entention est une porte
d'entrée supplémentaire pour
l'immigration sous prétexte économique
alors qu'il y a 2200000 demandeurs
d'emploi en France les métiers de
couvreur serveurs agent d'entretien ad
domicile ouvrier en travaux publics
conducteur de transport en commun ou
pharmacien dit en tension doivent être
valorisé par un allègement ou une
exonération de charges et une
revalorisation des salaires non pas par
une course au moins 10 ans salarial et
social cet article 3 est une concurrence
étrangère déloyale sur notre sol et une
trappe à bas salaire l'immigration n'est
pas la réponse il y a des solutions une
politique familiale incitative pour un
regain de la natalité française le
versement du RSA sous conditions de
travail comme dans les Bouches du rô le
recours à l'apprentissage la lutte
contre le recours excessif des salariés
prudomme toute cette politique doit être
débatue indépendamment de notre texte
sur l'immigration vous nous prenez en
otage si Français sur 10 estim qu'il y a
trop d'immigrés en France 7/ 10 pensent
que la politique migratoire est trop
laxiste ce qu'attendent les Français
c'est de la fermeté dans une étude parue
en 2021 l'Observatoire français des
conjonctures économiques a révélé que
pour seulement 1 % de travailleurs
immigrés supplémentaires les salaires
des ouvriers qualifiés des techniciens
et employés et des ouvriers non
qualifiés baisser notablement en France
le problème c'est que les salaires nets
sont bas et les salaires bruts sont
élevés la différence entre les deux
c'est le pognon de dingue de la dépense
sociale non contributive d'après les
dernières données de votre ministère en
2017 14 % des Français âgés de 15 ans ou
plus étaient chômeurs c'est 42 % des
Algériens 43 % des Marocains et 48 % des
des Turcs vivant en France c'est dans ce
sens que je vous invite que j'invite
ceux qui ne veulent pas de cette
disposition dans la loi ni par voie
règlementaire à voter mon amendement de
suppression merci monsieur le Président
merci quel est l'avis du Gouvernement
monsieur le ministre sur ces
défavorable je j'ai une demande
d'explication de vote de Monsieur
benaroche alors Monsieur
Cabanel merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues
il y a eu hier un un vrai faux pas celui
de la suppression de la me nous y avons
passé du temps nous avons espéré
convaincre avec d'autres mais en vain et
tout le monde a vite compris que cette
décision de notre assemblée n'avait rien
de rationnel et qu'elle se ne se
comprenait que comme le résultat d'une
idéologie quasi dogmatique de la
majorité
sénatoriale nous risquons à présent de
nous égarer une seconde fois si une
majorité accepte de renoncer
à la mesure intéressante de ce projet la
seule qui justifie finalement de passer
autant d'heure à examiner un niè texte
sur l'imigration cet article 3 manque
marque une bascule je vous l'accorde il
marque la fin d'une hpocrisie qui ça a
été dit qui veut que l'on interdise le
loi du travail clandestin tout en
l'approuvant quotidiennement dans les
fait il marque la fin d'une
marginalisation systématique d'une
catégorie d'employés qui travaillent
souvent dur pour des bas salaires
souvent sur des plages horaires
particulièrement exigeantes et toujours
pour l'intérêt de notre nation mais sans
jamais bénéficier du moins de droit et
d'une véritable reconnaissance sans
jamais pouvoir vraiment s'intégrer alors
que dans dans de nombreux cas notre pays
s'appuie sur eux notre groupe comptait
voter cet article 3 nous étions prêts à
concéder des aménagements et des
compromis mais nous voulions coûte que
coûte que cet article demeure dans le
texte à l'issue de l'examen de ce de
notre assemblée
lors de la discussion générale notre
Présidente nous avait bien réservé notre
position si vous ajoutez à la
suppression de laame celle de l'article
3 vous comprendrez donc qu'il n'y a pour
nous plus aucun espoir à ce que nous
soutenions ce
texte la parole est à Monsieur carucci
pour explication de
vote monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre beaucoup de choses ont été
dites sur les explications sur l'article
moi je voudrais seulement dire en
réalité entre vous et
[Musique]
nous la différence majeure c'est est-ce
que on crée un droit opposable une
automaticité ou est-ce qu'on fait du cas
par cas personne ne dit qu'un certain
nombre de d'immigrants en situation
irrégulière étant dans des secteurs
d'emploi compliqués ne doivent pas être
régularisés évidemment non attendez moi
je vous ai écouté alors vous m'écoutez
merci
merci les choses sont claires sauf que
nous allons passer et vous le savez bien
monsieur le ministre de 7 à 8000
régularisations par an ce qui est
aujourd'hui le cas par les préfets à un
nombre on va dire indéterminé je veux
pas m'engager plus personne n'en sait
rien en réalité personne n'en sait rien
mais c'est une automaticité extrêmement
dangereuse parce que je voudrais vous
rappeler monsieur le ministre et vous le
savez parfait
qu'indépendamment du chômage global de
quelques millions de personnes quand
même dans ce beau pays de France 500000
immigrés en situation régulière sont au
chômage 500000 immigrés en situation
régulière sont au chômage on est en
train si on fait de l'automaticité de
créer presque une concurrence déloyale
entre ceux qui ont suivi les règles et
qui sont là en situation régulière et
ceux qui ne sont pas en situation
régulière et qui pourrai être
régulariser de manière automatique donc
effectivement moi je préfère clairement
le fait de pouvoir régulariser au cas
par cas d'en rester au pouvoir des
préfets conformément à l'amendement qui
a été préparé par la commission c'est
pas une question de savoir si on est
pour le travail pas pour le travail
c'est simplement de se dire est-ce qu'il
faut donner une prime à des gens qui
sont rentrés de manière irrégulière qui
n'ont pas respecter les textes de loi
qui sont employés peut-être d'ailleurs
autrefois le groupe communiste aurait
dit par des poitrons voyou qui ne
respecte pas non plus les règles
pourquoi donner une prime à une double
irrégularité alors qu'on peut faire en
sorte de régulariser au cas par cas et
peut-être de trouver des voies de
passage pour que les immigrés en
situation régulière eux trouvent des
emplois monsieur carci la parole est à
Madame de la
gonri Merci monsieur le le président
pour explication de vote nous voterons
contre ces amendements puisque même si
l'article 3 ne répondait pas en totalité
à ce que nous estimons être nécessaire
en direction ces travailleurs nous
considérions que c'était une avancée
très importante c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs de voir depuis tout à l'heure
le le pas de deux
entre les rapporteurs le gouvernement le
groupe LR parce qu' au fond c'est assez
gênant Roger kouci dit à l'instant
personne ne conteste le fait qu'il
faille pouvoir régulariser des
travailleurs sans papier bah si j'ai
entendu exact l'inverse tout à l'heure
alors ensuite on parle de fraude moi je
voudrais simplement dire à à mon
collègue kucci il y a bien d'autres
domaines dans lequel les fraudes mais on
les appelle pas fraudes on les appelle
erreurs publiquement font l'objet de
régularisation dans le domaine fiscal
dans le domaine immobilier mais là on
appelle ça le droit à l'erreur là on
parle de fraude donc c'est intéressant
de voir comment les les mots sont
utilisés Roger carucci on se connaît
depuis longtemps donc les mines que vous
faites quand je parle ne me
déstabilisent plus depuis au moins 10
ans donc sur ce point donc nous sommes
en dessà de ce qui nous semble
nécessaire pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement le cas par cas alors
sur ce sur ce point ce que j'aimerais
c'est entendre le ministre s'exprimer
sur l'application de cette cette
disposition à venir donc vous avez
jusqu'aux qure bis finalement pour
réfléchir ou pas à à répondre à cette
question pouvez-vous affirmer entre
guillemets que les
préfectures appliqueront de manière
homogène le dispositif alors que nous
avons constaté c'est bien un un des
problèmes de la circulaire Vals que ce
n'était pas le cas et qu'il y avait un
grand nombre de préfectures qui ne les
appliquaient pas du
tout merci la parole est à monsieur le
président Bruno
retaillot il y a un un élément un
argument que que je je voudrais
développer je je ne reviens pas sur le
caractère automatique euh le fait que la
fraude crée un droit c'était vraiment
pour nous ce principe là qui nous
faisait que on ne pouvait pas accepter
en l'état monsieur le ministre l'article
3 euh simplement je veux appuyer sur le
point que et je l'ai dit en discussion
générale je pense qu'il y a une
aberration qui est de l'ordre d'une
capitulation quand on est à plus de 7 %
de taux de chômage pensez que pour
résoudre les problèmes de la pénurie
d'emploi c'est nécessairement cette
immigration illégale clandestine qu'on
doit régulariser il y a quelque chose
comme de l'ordre de l'abandon je me
souviens très bien il y a quasiment jour
pour jour c'était en 93 c'était à la fin
du mois d'octobre quand François
mitteran à la télévision vient dire que
on était rendu pratiquement à 3 millions
de chômeurs en France et il vient devant
les caméras il s'explique et il dit vous
savez sur le chôage on a tout essayé et
bien je pense que l'idée de
régularisation massive de faire appel à
cette immigration clandestine pour
régler finalement ces problèmes de
pénurie d'emploi c'est de l'ordre c'est
pareil c'est comme si on disait mais
contre la pénurie d'emploi on a tout
essayé non on n pas tout essayé Roger
carucci faisait allusion à ces plus de
500000 travailleurs enfin qui ne sont
pas travailleurs qui sont étrangers en
situation régulière qui sont au chômage
1400000 jeunes qui sont sans emploi qui
sont même pas à l'école 1900000 français
et français au RSA 3 millions de
Français au chômage qu'est-ce qu'on fait
d'eux on les laisse tomber voilà je
pense que cette argumentation elle est
quelque part à entendre aussi non on n
pas tout essayé contre les pénuries
d'emploi et c'est certainement pas avec
des petits salaires mes chers collègues
de gauche vous devriez être sensible à
cet argument c'est certainement pas en
payant des gens clandestins avec un
lancepierre qu'on va régler ce problème
là monsieur le ministre vous avez
monsieur le ministre vous avez demander
la parole
oui merci beaucoup juste
prés juste dire au président moi je suis
sensible à cette argumentation bien bien
évidemment cependant que ce soit
l'article 3 ou l'article 4 B et le 3
évidemment c'est opposable 4 B c'est au
cas par
cas mais c'est un fait mais c'est c'est
un fait que c'est une on va pas
recommencer c'est un fait que c'est une
régularisation monsieur le Président
Raillot bien
bon ce que je voulais vous dire c'est
que je suis sensible à votre
argumentation c'est pour ça que dans
l'amendement dans le texte du
Gouvernement il y avait la zone
géographique c'estàdire que voilà donc
métier ention c'est pas tous les métiers
d'ailleurs je vous rappelle que c'est un
une publication du du ministre du
Travail qui chaque année voilà et
deuxièmement C zones géographiqu tendu
vous auriez pu rajouter des critères
d'ailleurs vous pourvez toujours le
faire sur le fait qu'il y a des zones
géographiques qui connaissaient le
dispositif et des zones géographiques
qui ne le connaissaient pas la Bretagne
n'a pas les même difficultés enfin a
plus de difficultés d'emploi que les
haut de France voilà donc c'était aussi
pour cela et et c'est vrai que j'ai un
argument peut-être monsieur le Président
rillot sur votre question d'appel d'air
ou c'est quoi cet article si on on part
du principe que les choses sont jouées
pour la la séance du Sénat donc vraiment
en dehors de tout toute polémique et
sans
convaincre c'est un article qui évoque
le fait que des personnes qui sont déjà
sur le territoire national qu'on ne peut
pas expulser vous seriez dans ma
responsabilité vous ne pourriez pas les
expulser monsieur le Président rotou
puisse accéder effectivement lorsqu'ils
sont dans les métiers en tenstion à des
régularisations parce qu'on a besoin de
cette manœuvre parce que qu'est-ce qui
va se passer dans les régions comme la
Bretagne par exemple qui ont très peu de
chômage vous allez importer une main
d'œuvre régulière qu'est-ce qui se passe
pour la FNSEA de la Bretagne pour la
FNSEA du du sud de la France vous le
savez bien ou pour d'autres
d'utre grande fédération professionnelle
bah ils vont demander des visas travail
pour que les gens viennent travailler
dans les chambres d'agriculture dans
ramasser des fraises à Plougastel ou
donc vous non mais il y aura sais il y a
pas que des saisonniers voilà don il y a
pas que des saisonniers et il y a
beaucoup de saisonniers qui restent par
ailleurs vous le savez très bien vous
savez très bien que le dispositif
demandé par des grandes fédérations
professionnelles c'est pas 100 % des
personnes qui repartent et c'est aussi
une trappe à irrégularité donc si on
veut vraiment se dire dire la vérité
absolue donc je pose que ce qui est
important de voir aussi c'est que c'est
une manière aussi de se dire monsieur le
Président Rago que ça a limité une
partie de l'immigration légal économique
qui ensuite fait droit à un regoupement
familial et cetera donc voilà une fois
qu'on a dit ça moi je v dire je suis
sensible et le gouvernement est sensible
à l'argument il n'est pas là pour
remplacer le travail qu'on doit faire
que les Français ou les étrangers
réguliers doivent pouvoir se former
parfois avoir la mobilité gérographique
on le fait avec le texte assurant
chômage vous le savez bien ce qui est
vrai c'est que c'est pas si facile que
ça c'est c'est pas si facile que ça de
prendre des gens qui travaillent dans la
restauration dans l' Haut- France pour
qu'ils aillent travailler dans
l'agriculture en
Bretagne merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole à Monsieur
brossa merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je voulais je vais
pas revenir sur toutes les raisons qui
font que nous nous regrettons que que le
Sénat s'apprête à supprimer l'article 3
mais je voulais revenir sur deux
arguments qui ont été évoqués depuis
tout à l'heure et et que je voudrais
contester très fortement d'abord cette
idée qui me paraît proprement euh
ahurissante et démentie par par tous les
faits selon laquelle la régularisation
de travailleurs sans papiers
constituerait une forme de dumping qui
nuirait au reste des travailleurs au
travailleurs français ou au travailleurs
euh étrangers en situation régulière
c'est l'inverse c'est l'inverse c'est le
maintien sur le le le territoire de
travailleurs qui sont sans papiers et
qui sont en concurrence avec des
travailleurs qui ont des qui constitue
du dumping c'est d'avoir deux catégories
de travailleurs sur notre sol qui tirent
tout le monde vers le bas des
travailleurs qui ont des papiers qui ont
des droits d'un côté et des travailleurs
qui n'ont pas de papier et qui n'ont pas
de droit de l'autre au contraire la
régularisation c'est ce qui permet
d'éviter le dumping social et c'est la
raison qui nous fait dire que la
régularisation de ces travailleurs qui
sont déjà là constituerait une bonne
nouvelle pour le monde du travail dans
son ensemble deè 2è argument l'idée
selon selon laquelle il y aurait une
responsabilité égale entre l'exploiteur
et l'exploité c'est proprement
incroyable de dire des choses pareilles
dire que à la fraude du salarié
correspondrait une fraude de même nature
ou de même gravité qui serait celle de
l'employeur qui fait le choix d'utiliser
une main d'œuvre clandestine enfin
écoutez c'est c'est c'est on n' pas le
droit de dire des choses pareilles
évidemment que la responsabilité
première c'est la responsabilité de
celui qui exploite et de celui qui
siamment fait le choix d'embaucher des
travailleurs sans papier pour les payer
moins cher et leur imposer des
conditions de travail
déplorables la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe
B le micro
fonctionne monsieur le ministre
j'interviens au soutien de la
suppression de l'article 3 à laquelle
vous vous opposez vous nous avez dit
tout à l'heure et je veux être précis
j'ai noté
exactement votre propos qu'on dise au
moins la vérité sur ce qu'est le fond de
cet article et vous nous avez expliqué
que le fond de cet article consistait à
préciser dans la loi des critères pour
l'exercice par l'état de son pouvoir de
régularisation et bien non monsieur le
ministre le fond de l'article que vous
nous présentez ça n'est pas du tout cela
c'est de changer de système pour passer
d'un système qui
crée la faculté pour l'État à titre
exceptionnel de
régulariser un étranger clandestin dans
un emploi relevant d'une liste de
métiers en tension un système qui crée
un droit et après tout puisque vous
demandez vous-même qu'on soit précis et
qu'on dise au moins la vérité je vais la
dire tout simplement en lisant votre
texte l'étranger qui a exercé une
activité professionnelle je vous épargne
les conditions qui sont posées il a en
effet un certain nombre de conditions se
voit délivrer de plein droit une carte
de séjour temporaire se voit délivré de
plein droit là où il n'y avait pas de
droit vous créez un droit et c'est ce
qui fait toute la différence entre vous
et nous nous ne voulons pas rentrer dans
un système qui crée un droit à la
régularisation des travailleurs
clandestins ça n'est bon ni pour
l'employeur qui se livre à une tel
fraude ni pour le travailleur clandestin
qui s'est introduit dans notre pays sans
titre et qui travaille dans une
situation parfaitement
Topale la parole est à Madame
rossignol
merci monsieur le Président en fait
depuis hier il y a une phrase qu'on a un
peu entendu même qui est revenu souvent
qui a une espèce de postulat c'est
l'intégration est en échec l'échec de
l'intégration déjà sur cette phrase là
al on aurait mériter d'avoir un peu plus
de discussion parce que je ne partage
pas l'idée que l'intégration est un
échec il y a énormément de personnes qui
sont issues de l'immigration même des
personnes qui sont arrivées récemment et
qui sont parfaitement intégré mais cela
ne sont pas dans vos écran radar ceuxl
ne sont pas dans vos écrans radar ceuxl
vous ne les voyez pas parce que ils ne
font pas de bruit et je vais mê vous
dire une chose il y a même des tas de
gens qui sont ce que vous appelez des
fraudeurs ou des clandestins que nous on
appelle plutôt des sansapiier et qui
sont parfaitement intégrés qui ne font
pas de bruit qui travaillent et qui
élèvent leurs enfants et qui montrent
qu'il y a pas que l'échec de
l'intégration ce serait bien qu'un jour
vous puissiez un peu changer de de de
regard ce qui m dans votre dans vos
amendements et avec le suivant c'est
qu'en fait ce que vous proposez c'est le
statut quo empire c'est-à-dire une
nouvelle fabrique à clandestin en fait
vous vous en arrangez très bien des
clandestins parce que ce que nous savons
tous c'est qu'ils vont continuer
d'occuper ses emplois qui vont continuer
d'être là qui ne vont pas être expulsés
qui vont rester sur le territoire
français mais vous vous serez content
parce que vous aurez fait beaucoup
d'agitation politique vous aurez essayé
de les plus fort que vos deux collègues
qui déposent les mêmes amendements que
vous c'està-dire ceux le zémourien et le
leopéniste qui déposent les mêmes
amendements non mais pouvez vous pouvez
en être choqué vous avez quatre
amendements de toutes les droites du
Sénat des
centristes à Zemour dépose le même
amendement avec des discours plus ou
moins en tonalité plus ou moins haute
plus ou moins basse mais vous avez le
même but plus
d'article
la parole est à Madame l'oratrice s'il
vous plaît madame r c'est
fait la parole est à Monsieur benarog
pour explication de
vote merci monsieur le Président moi je
remercie d'abord Philippe B parce que
Philippe B dit la vérité et je la
partage avec lui il est vrai il est vrai
que initialement ce gouvernement pensait
qu'il fallait régulariser
automatiquement un certain nombre de
travail ailleurs parce que ça
permettrait une meilleure intégration de
ces travailleurs dans notre pays et que
ça permettrait en particulier de faire
que des gens sans papier aujourd'hui qui
travaillent en France et qui sont
parfaitement intégrés à la société le
Soi totalement parce qu'ils ne peuvent
pas l'être totalement tant qu'ils n'ont
pas cette régularisation par le travail
qui leur permet de ne pas avoir en
permanence au-dessus d'eux ce couperé
possible qui est celui de l'expulsion et
du départ de la France donc je remercie
monsieur le bas d'avoir dit la vérité je
remercie monsieur le ministre Darmanin
et Monsieur le Ministre du S d'avoir eu
cette excellente idée et je m'aperçois
que pour des calcul uniquement
politicien uniquement politicien qui que
je comprends très bien puisqu'on fait
tous de la politique y compris de la
politique politicienne avoir abdiqué
abdiqué tous Monsieur B tous Voilà
d'avoir abdiqué et d'avoir renoncé à
cette idée qui nous semblait excellente
que nous étions prêts à avec laquelle
nous étions prêts à avancer même à
améliorer et d'avoir uniquement abdiqué
pour des raisons qui sont celles d'un
calcul politique et politicien en
sachant en plus messieurs et mesdames
les sénateurs on nous l'a dit hier donc
je me permets de le répéter puisqu'on
nous l'a dit ouvertement que de toute
façon dans la réalité aussi bien le
ministre qu'un certain nombre de membres
du gouvernement savent très bien que
tout ce que nous votons ici sera soumis
et remis en cause par le vote de
l'Assemblée nationale où ils espèrent
que les choses sont différentes donc je
ne voudrais pas dire que nous
travaillons en 20 mais je voudrais juste
e dire aujourd'hui que pour des tas de
raisons il faut régulariser les
travailleurs sans papier si on veut pas
renoncer à l'intégration et à
l'intégration de ces travailleurs en
France où il où ils sont déjà depuis des
années mais que pour des raisons
uniquement de rapport politique nous
abdiquons cette idée et je le regrette
profondément merci monsieur benaroche
mes chers collègues j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public sur ces quatre
amendements identiques par le groupe
soci écologiste et républicain par le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire et par la commission des
lois je vous rappelle que l'avis du
Gouvernement est
défavorable le scrutin est
ouvert
demande à
voter c'est bon le scrutin est
clos donc après ça
tombe
nombre de votants
345 mes chers collègues nombre de
votants 345 nombre de suffrage exprimés
329 pour
191 contre 138 le Sénat a adopté
l'amendement de suppression de l'article
3 l'article 3 est supprimé et les
amendements suivants
tombent
bien nous en venons un article
additionnel après l'article 3 je propose
à Monsieur
Cabanel de défendre l'amendement 34
monsieur
bilac il est
défendu
monsieur mass vous avez la
parolearon monsieur le
Président je précise c'est ma première
intervention monsieur le ministre et
chers
collègues cet amendement a pour objet de
fluidifier l'introduction de salari
étrangers venant exercer un emploi
caractère saisonnier dans entreprise de
la production agricole et dont la
résidence habituelle et hors de
France donc en supprimant l'obligation
pour les employeurs de justifier que
leur offre d'emploi saisonnier ne trouve
pas de candidat en
France en effet aujourd'hui le marché de
l'emploi français ne permet plus de
répondre à l'offre d'emploi saisonniers
agricole ce décalage a été révélé de
façon criante pendant la crise
sanitaire les raisons si elles sont
multiples se concentrent autour des
problèmes d'attractivité de ces métiers
et d'évolution de la société et je
rassouterai également et de notre mode
de
consommation
or malgré les investissements permanents
de la
profession malgré les investissements
également des pouvoirs publics pour
remédier à ce constat le résultat reste
20 cette amendement permettrait de
régler une des difficultés rencontrées
pour ce type d'embauche et c'est un
département dont l'activité économique
et principalement le monde agricole donc
qui sait ce qu'il vous dit qui en
difficulté aujourd'hui
merci merci Monsieur Masset pour
l'amendement
99 il est défendu merci Monsieur
KNE quel est l'avis de de la commission
madame le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
vous proposez chers collègues que la
situation de l'emploi ne soit pas
opposable pour le recrutement de
saisonnés étrangers dans les entreprises
de production agricole je proposerais
surtout et bien que si véritablement il
y a des difficultés je peux parfaitement
l'entendre les emplois soient inclus
dans la liste des métiers en tension ce
qui permettrait effectivement que la
situation de l'emploi ne soit pas
opposable et et nous verrons sans doute
tout à l'heure un amendement qui va
permettre d'examiner plus souvent cette
liste des métiers en tension si tel est
le cas et bien effectivement il ne sera
pas utile de pouvoir justifier la
situation de l'emploi c'est un avis de
retrait sinon défavorable quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre même avis donc je mets au
voix les amendements identique avec un
avis une
demande
alors avec une demande de retrait de la
part de la Commission sinon un avis
défavorable et même avis du gouvernement
euh l'amendement 34 est
maintenu il est
maintenu très bien l'amendement 99 est
retiré donc je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement
34 qui est avec avec les avis que j'ai
précisé qui est
pour qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté article
additionnel après l'article 3 deux
amendements fais t l'objet d'une
discussion commune le premier le
283 est défendu par Monsieur
jade merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
droite sénatoriale ça va vous
plaît le présent amendement a pour
objectif simple celui de permettre aux
personnes bénéficiant d'un premier titre
de séjour pour une activité salariée
d'entrepreneur ou de profession libérale
d'accéder un titre plurannuel de 3
ans le ministre l'a rappelé combien le
renouvellement des titres de séjour
pouvait s'avérer difficile parfois
cfcayen mettant les salariés qui ont un
premier titre de séjour dans des dans
d'immenses difficultés donc nous
proposons effectivement
d'étendre le titre de ses jours d'une
durée de 3 ans pour faire en sorte pour
alléger le travail dans les préfectures
rendre l'intégration plus facile et le
travail plus facile au service de toutes
et de tous et puis puisque j'ai encore
un peu de temps je voulais juste vous
dire quand dans l'article que vous allez
proposer qui intègre les modes de vie
notamment dans tous ces travailleurs
sans papier et ben il y a ceux qui
travaillent dans les cuisines des
restaurants et c'est ceux qui
aujourd'hui savent cuisiner toute la
cuisine française
merci merci la parole est à Madame carer
pour l'amendement 33 merci monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues monsieur
le ministre cet amendement a été proposé
bien sûr dans le prolongement de
l'article 3 du projet de loi qui
prévoyait donc la création d'un nouveau
titre de séjour métier en tenstion hélas
notre Assemblée a fait le choix de le
supprimer je ne me fais donc pas grande
illusion sur ce sort de cette
proposition pourtant je crois que le
constat sur lequel elle s'appuie
pourrait nous inviter à décider autre
ement vous le savez il existe de
nombreux cas où les étrangers sans titre
de séjour valable travaillent depuis
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
malgré la la clandestinité quels que
soient les métiers exercés ces personnes
sont le plus souvent parfaitement
intégrées et participent par leurs
activités à la vie de notre pays hélas
le plus souvent les employeurs refusent
de prendre le risque de déclarer ses
travailleurs et ainsi les laissent dans
une situation de précarité de dépendance
en leur bloquant l'accès au titre de
séjour l'une des raisons de cette
irrégularité repose sur l'absence
d'autorisation de travail pour ses
employés avec comme conséquence
l'impossibilité pour l'employeur de les
déclarer régulièrement et par exemple de
leur produire des fiches de paye nous
proposons donc que la demande et
l'obtention d'un titre séjour mention
salarié puisse être réalisée sans cette
autorisation à condition que le
travailleur puisse justifier d'une
activité professionnelle suffisante je
vous remercie merci Madame carer quel
sont les avis de la commission madame le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
sur l'amendement 283 présenté par
Monsieur Jade mon cher collègue vous
proposez en fait d'emblé qu'un étranger
puisse bénéficier d'un d'un titre de
séjour en lien avec le travail
extrêmement long enfin de 3 ans le
principe dans le droit des étrangers qui
souffre des exceptions mais c'est tout
de même le principe et qu'on commence
toujours par un titre court un titre qui
permet aussi d'évaluer la capacité
d'intégration donc c'est un avis
défavorable quand à l'amendement 33
présenté par notre collègue la
présidente carer et bien il vise chers
collègues mais vous le savez à
réintroduire d'une façon quelque peu
différente le dispositif de l'article 3
vous l'avez indiqué vous-même donc vous
imaginez bien que venant d'être supprimé
ça sera un avis
défavorable quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur le ministre même
avis je mets au voix les l'amendement
283 avec avis défavorable de la
commission et du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre contre il n'est pas
adopté je mets au voix l'amendement
33 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas
adopté article additionnel après
l'article
3 un amendement présenté par Madame de
Monsieur Durin merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement vise à dénoncer
une une hypocrisie supprimer la
restriction selon laquelle une carte de
séjour métier en tension ne pourra être
délivrée qu'en raison d'une activité
professionnelle salariée et j'allais
dire cette hypocrisie au sens propre et
au sens figuré elle court les rues cette
mention exclut les travailleurs des
plateformes qui en droit français n'ont
pas le statut de salarié oui il faut
sortir de cette hypocrisie parce que la
relation de travail entre une entreprise
de plateforme et les travailleurs qui
lui sont liés a toutes les
caractéristiques d'une relation salarié
ces entreprises ne sont pas de simples
intermédiaires entre des prestataires et
des clients et les travailleurs de ces
plateformes loin d'être des indépendants
sont sous le contrôle de l'entreprise
ces entreprises fixent le prix des
courses déterminent des horair
préférentiel organise les conditions de
travail au quotidien il y a donc très
souvent un lien de subordination comme
l'a arrêté à plusieurs occasions la Cour
de cassation et si on raisonnait par
l'absurde à contrario partons du
principe que ces étrangers qui
travaillent pour ces plateformes ne sont
pas des salariés en quoi cela
justifie-t-il qu'il ne puisse pas être
régularisé ces travailleurs contribuent
à des pend entier de l'économie et la
seule réponse du gouvernement est donc
de faire comme s'il n'existe pas ne pas
les prendre en compte ce n'est pas une
politique c'est juste mettre la tête
dans le sable merci mon cher collègue
quel est l'avis de la commission madame
le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
l'avis de la commission n'est pas n'est
pas favorable l'extension de la
circulaire Vals vous vous vous en doutez
n'est pas véritablement la solution nous
privilégions pour ce problème qui est un
problème réel je n'en disconviens pas la
solution peut-être à privilégier sur
laquelle il faut travailler mais et
certains d'entre nous dans cette amiie
qui ont travaillé puisqueune une PPL a
été déposée et sans doute la solution
contractuelle il conviendrait de
basculer vers un régime contractuel des
travailleurs des plateformes c'est en
tout cas ce qui serait plutôt
privilégié l'avis du Gouvernement
monsieur le ministre même avis je mets
au voix la l'amendement 223 avec un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
article additionnel après l'article 3
avec un amendement numéro 405 défendu
par Madame Vogel j'ai la parole chers
collègue merci monsieur le Président
alors c'est un amendement assez simple
et qui va pas soulever les f j'espère
qui consiste simplement à dire
aujourd'hui l'État français met à
disposition des personnes étrangères qui
résident en France des informations
relatives à leur droit leurs devoirs et
cetera si elles souhaitent s'installer
durablement comme vous avez largement
durci les conditions pour les personnes
qui ne résident pas encore en France
notamment celles qui sont candidates au
regroupement familial pour pouvoir y
accéder et qu'elles n'y sont pas encore
nous proposons que nous mettions aussi à
disposition dans les consulats français
les informations sur les mêmes droits et
sur les mêmes devoirs de sorte que ces
personnes qui sont déjà obligés
d'attendre 2 ans maintenant de maîtriser
le français et cetera puissent au moins
avoir les mêmes formation que celles et
ceux qui résident déjà en France je vous
remercie et je voulais juste préciser
que le 406 est
retiré merci chers collègues quel est
l'avis de la commission madame le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission a été
d'estimé que cette information faisait
plutôt sens dans les consulats
c'est-à-dire avant de venir qu'ailleurs
et c'est donc un avis défavorable
puisque ou une demande de retrait
puisque c'est déjà le cas et du
gouvernement monsieur le
ministre je mets au voix l'amendement
405 avec avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté je vous informe pour ceux qui
l'ont dans l'alliace que l'amendement
264 a été retiré ainsi que l'amendement
269 ainsi que le
265 nous en arrivons à l'amendement 515
pour un article additionnel après
l'article
3assen vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président il s'agit d'un
d'une demande de rapport sur les
conditions d'accès à la fonction
publique pour les étrangers non
européens et les conséquences de leur
statut d'agents contractuel de droit
public pour leur intégration et en état
des lieux des difficultés de recrutement
dans la fonction publique monsieur le
ministre il s'agit en réalité d'un d'un
amendement d'appel puisque il n'était
pas possible de déposer sans que ce soit
un cavalier législatif des des
amendements au au droit de la fonction
publique mais nous voulons ouvrir le
débat sur le fait que dans la fonction
publique aussi il y a des métiers
entention il y a 600 emplois qui ne sont
pas qui n'ont pas été pourvu l'an
dernier dans la fonction publique détail
la fonction publique territoriale eu et
il semble absurde de ne pas modifier
notre législation afin d'ouvrir la
possibilité de ces emplois à des
étrangers non européens il y a des
beaucoup d'emplois pour lesquels il n'a
pas de nécessité d'être français ou ou
ou européen euh et il y a aussi euh dans
les emplois pourvus beaucoup d'emplois
non peu qualifiés comme dans les
collectivités territoriales par exemple
pour les la les emplois dans la propreté
mais aussi les emplois qualifiés qui
sont occupés aujourd'hui de manière
contractuelle par des étrangers non
communautaires dans des situations de
précarité très fortte euh quant à leur
statut euh de de travail parfois il se
retrouve momentanément en situation
irrégulière euh par parce qu'ils ont des
difficultés parce que c'est un un
parfois un millefeuille administrative
que de faire renouveler son titre de
séjour ou obtenir une carte
pluriannuelle et ce qui aussi complique
la vie de nos collectivités de
territoriales et et donc il serait aussi
bon que des simplification et soit mise
en œuvre pour aussi les sécuriser dans
leur statut merci merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame le rapporteur
pour l'avis de la commission merci
monsieur monsieur président l'avis de la
commission s'agissant d'une demande de
rapport et vous le savez par principe
défavorable sur le fond la question que
nous étions posé et et de savoir si ces
étrangers en se lançant dans un
processus de naturalisation
d'acquisition de la nationalité
française ne pourrait pas aussi
manifester leur volonté de participer la
communauté nationale et ainsi de pouvoir
entrer dans la fonction
publique quel est l'avis du Gouvernement
monsieur le
ministre donc je mets au voix amendement
515 avec un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté nous en sommes à l'amendement
460 présenté il est retiré monsieur le
Président il est
retiré mes chers collègues nous en
arrivons à l'article 4 j'ai une demande
prise de parole sur cet article de la
part de Monsieur guimén
roche merci monsieur le Président je
voulais
profiter du début de de l'étude de cet
article pour répondre à à deux
interpellations après les discussion
générale de pris de de de géralde
armanin concernant un certain nombre
d'idées que nous avions évoqué et qui
concern effectivement le le l'article 4
la première c'est que monsieur le
ministre vous vous m'aviez demandé vous
nous aviez interpellé en séance en nous
disant qu'il fallait se poser les
questions qui correspondent non pas à
des présupposés des postures mais bien à
de la réalité ça concernait en fait les
crédits de Lada et vous m'avez expliqué
que les crédits de l'ADA c'était normal
qu'il soit pas en augmentation puisque
vu le texte qui allait être proposé et
voté il était normal que ces crédits
soient pas en augmentation pour 2024 en
fait vous n'iez pas tout à fait entendu
ce que je vous disais puisque ce que je
vous répète aujourd'hui c'est que les
crédits de Lada ont été baissé dès le
PLF 2023 monsieur le ministre
d'intérieur et qu'à mon avis au moment
du PLF
2023 personne de ce fait avec les les
les la baisse de ses crédits n'a pu
bénéficier du coup de l'efficacité que
vous attribuez à votre texte pour 2024
et de la réduction des délais de
traitement qui de toute façon ne
rentrera en vigueur qu'en
2024 et pas en 2023 la 2ème réponse
c'était concernant la vision euh
du modèle ukrainien et du modèle
d'accueil ukrainien et vous m'aviez d
chiche à ce moment-là faisant en sorte
que tous les accueils sot temporaire
c'était pas l'objet de ce que nous
proposons au sein du groupe nous ce que
nous disons nous savons très bien que
les Ukrainiens sont pas dans un parcours
d'asile ce que nous disons c'est que la
prise en charge qui a été faite des
Ukrainiens indépendamment de leur
vocation ou non à rester sur le
territoire et le modèle que nous
souhaitons voir dupliquer je vous
confirme qu'avec notre groupe nous
pensons que l'inconditionnalité de la
dignité dans l'accueil même temporaire
même sans préjugé de la poursuite de
matiens sur le territoire soit en
attendant de repartir dans un pays en
paix pour les Ukrainiens soit en
attendant les décisions de l'asile doit
être la
même la parole est à Madame Vogel sur
l'article oui merci monsieur le
Président alors je voulais juste quand
même intervenir sur ce qui est contenu
dans cet article puisque vous voulez le
supprimer et qu'on va discuter tout de
suite l'amendement de la commission de
suppression cet article c'est quoi c'est
un article qui permet à des demandeurs
d'asile qui sont en France qui ont un
taux de protection très élevé parce que
nous savons que ces personnes viennent
de pays où on est quasiment certain
qu'on va leur accorder l'asile parce que
ils viennent d'Afghanistan de Syrie et
cetera et donc en gros il y a un moment
entre la le moment où la personne fait
la demande et le moment où elle obtient
l'asile qui est long parce que nous
sommes l à leur répondre mais on est
certain que ces personnes vont avoir
l'asile politique en
France cet article il propose simplement
de dire pendant que cette personne n'a
pas encore eu la réponse à cause de nous
pas à cause d'elle alors qu'on sait très
bien que la réponse va être positive
puisqueon sait que c'est une personne
qui vient d'Afghanistan et qu'en gros on
donne l'asile en soin à toutes les
personnes qui viennent d'Afghanistan on
la laisse travailler travailler payer
des cotisations payer des impôts et
cetera c'est c'est ça le contenu de
l'article et vous êtes contre et je
comprends pas je je ne comprends pas
comment on peut être contre le fait
qu'une personne qui est là dont on sait
qu'on va lui donner le droit de rester
on en est sûr on le sait simplement on
est trop long à le faire comment on peut
être opposer au fait que cette personne
ait le droit de travailler donc de
servir la société de payer des impôts de
payer des cotisations sociales nos
cotisations social les cotisations
sociales pour tout le monde nos
retraites vos retraites comment on peut
s'opposer à ça
je ne comprends pas nous avons fait ça
pour les Ukrainiennes et les Ukrainiens
qui sont arrivés en France parce qu'ils
avaient la protection temporaire tout le
monde a salué ce système qui a très bien
marché c'est simplement d'assurer qu'il
puisse être cohérent avec les personnes
qui n'ont pas la protection temporaire
il n'y a aucun sens à s'y opposer
j'aimerais que vous m'expliquiez
pourquoi merci mes chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur
B je voudrais répondre à notre collègue
madame Vogel pourquoi parce qu'il faut
s'assurer que c'est bien un
Afghan que il a réellement de bonnes
chances de pouvoir
bénéficier du droit d'asile on ne le
sait que quand on a examiné le dossier
interroger la personne vérifier que ça
n'est pas quelqu'un qui va être un
déboutter du droit d'asile parce qu'il
aura abusé de la procédure en se faisant
passer justement pour quelqu'un de
exécuté alors qu'il ne l'était
pas la parole est à Monsieur
brossa merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre au fond Mélanie
Vogel a dit beaucoup de choses avec
lesquelles je suis d'accord mais au fond
la question est assez simple est de
savoir si on préfère que les gens vivent
de leur travail ou si on préfère que les
gens vivent des revenus de l'assistance
et je suis quand même un peu étonné de
voir les les sénateurs
la droite de cet hémicycle nous
expliquer qu'il préfère que les gens
vivent de l'assistance plutôt que du
travail je considère et nous sommes
nombreux je crois à considérer que ce
qui permet à quelqu'un d'être digne
c'est de gagner sa vie par son travail
en l'occurrence on parle de gens qui
sont demandeurs d'asile et qui aspirent
à travailler à vivre de leur travail à
être utile à la société par leur travail
et en l'occurrence vous les renvoyez
vers des revenus d'assistance
c'est-à-dire je crois pour un demandeur
d'asile 6,80 € par jour que des gens
préfèrent de préfèrent travailler et et
la possibilité d'accéder au travail me
paraître une bonne chose et l'un des
meilleurs moyen d'intégration dans notre
pays merci la parole est à Madame de La
Gonterie merci monsieur le Président
beaucoup d'arguments ont été énoncés
mais je pense qu'il faut quand même bien
fixer les choses pour ne pas développer
de de fantasmes
irraisonnés moi j'ai bien écouté les
arguments de de nos collègues sur
l'article 3 et le refus
de d'un titre de plein
droit privilégiant la possibilité et
donc la possibilité de l'autorité
administrative de délivrer ou non c'est
exactement ce que prévoit l'article 4
l'article 4 ne prévoit pas une
autorisation de plein droit il est dit
peu peu en en droit c'est ce n'est pas
doit bien donc l'article le 4 devrait
vous satisfaire dans sa rédaction alors
ensuite il s'agit de savoir quels sont
les les les pays d'origine qui pourrai
être concernés l'étude d'impact parle
alors c'est un taux de protection qui
serait défini année après année très
bien l'étude d'impact 10 50 % regardons
de quoi nous parlons il y a aujourd'hui
9 pays dont essentiellement Afghanistan
ééritrée et
Syrie qui bénéficient dont les
ressortissants bénéficient d'un taux de
de plus de 50 % enfin la formule n'est
pas très orthodoxe en français mais je
crois que vous m'avez compris entre
septembre 2021 et septembre 2022 il y a
eu savez-vous combien de de personnes
concernées et qui ont eu une
autorisation de travail
354 donc on est en train de supprimer
enfin vous voulez supprimer un article
qui donc laisse la main totalement à
l'autorité administrative et ne donne
pas un titre de droit confirmement votre
souhait et qui par ailleurs viserait
quelques centaines de personnes qui en
revanche n'auraiit pas à attendre
plusieurs mois car le délai c'est 6 mois
puis ensuite enfin en gros c'est au
moins 9 mois qui pendant ce temps bah
soit travaille au noir soit vivent
effectivement de combien d'euros par
jour 6 € voilà donc je pense qu'il faut
que vous revisitiez un petit peu votre
appréciation sur cet article 4 qui est
beaucoup plus conforme à ce que vous
souhait que ce que vous disiez ou ce que
vous pensiez
dire merci la parole Paro est à Madame
Brossel merci monsieur le Président on a
beaucoup parler d'hypocrisie dans le
débat sur la suppression de l'article 3
on pourrait tout autant parler de
d'hypocrisie sur cette amendement qui va
nous être proposé de suppression le
problème c'est que c'est de l'hypocrisie
doublée d'un dénis de réalité alors
pardon je vais permettre à la réalité de
reprendre pied quelques instants dans ce
débat à Paris entre le 18e le 19e
arrondissement de l'été 2022 à octobre
2023 il y a eu 12 mises à l'abri de
campement de personnes 5000 personnes
mises à l'abri au cours de 12 mises à
l'abri je répète les chiffres parce que
ça a du sens quand même sur lesquels sur
ces campements il y avait et des
demandeurs d'asile en cours de demande
et des demandeurs d'asile statutairees
des personnes à qui la France a accordé
sa protection statutaire et qui on étit
réduite à avoir comme lieu de vie les
trottoirs de Paris c'est de l'indignité
absolue et vous proposez aujourd'hui y
compris au regard des chiffres que
rappelait Marie-Pierre de la Gonterie de
revenir sur cet article 4 c'est écoutez
au-delà de l'hypocrisie je le répète
c'est un dénis absolu de réalité et nous
ne pouvons pas faire la loi sans prendre
en contre la
réalité merci la parole est à Madame
rossignol
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon merci monsieur le Président en
fait j'ai bien écouté notre collègue
Philippe Bas je l'écoute avec attention
toujours et je pense qu' il y a un
malentendu sur cet article 4 le
malentendu d'abord c'est que cet article
4 que vous soupçonnez en
fait d'ouvrir des droits à des futurs
déboué du droit
d'asile vous êtes méfiant vous êtes même
précautionneux mais c'est article 4 il
n'a pas été rédigé ni par Madame Vogel
ni par Madame de La Gonterie ni par
Monsieur brossa il a été rédigé par le
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur daran
qui à ma connaissance n'est pas le
militant le plus no bordeur que j'ai
rencontré dans ma vie on peut au voilà
et vous pourriez au moins faire le
crédit à Monsieur Darmanin qu'il n'est
pas là pour accroître le nombre de
déboutés du droit d'asile bénéficiant
d'une autorisation de travailler qui
ferait de ensuite des clandestins qu'on
ne pourrait plus jamais renvoyer
adminima faites confiance à votre
ami Gérard Géral d'Anin faites confiance
à ses services et faites confiance à sa
volonté de
traquer les futures débouté du droit
d'asile et croyez-moi d'un point de vue
économique vous faites une erreur parce
que ces demandeurs d'asile du moment où
il déposent une demande d'asile il
touche la D vous le savez et il vaut
bien mieux qu'il travaille puisque dans
l'article 4 tous les verrous ont été mis
de façon à ce que seul bénéficie de cet
article 4 ceux qui sont quasiment
certain d'obtenir le droit d'asile donc
je me retrouve dans la situation
étonnante baroque de plaider pour que la
droite du Sénat fasse confiance au
ministre de droite gerérald
d'manin merci
monsieur le
ministre je m'exprime en tant que
ministre de l'Intérieur et pas en tant
que ne
borddeur soyez pas ne soyez pas soyez
pas déçu non quelques mots peut-être sur
l'article 4 don j'imagine qu'il sera
supprimé dans dans quelques instants
malheureusement
malheureusement quelle est la
philosophie de cette article et je
voudrais dire à monsieur le Président
bah qui qui si je peux me permettre il
se trompe il est évident que nous
donnons une autorisation de travail que
dans les cas où l'identification est
évidente c'est tellement vrai que comme
l' très bien fait remarqué je crois que
c'était madame de La Gonterie c'est peu
c'est c'est pour le coup c'est pas de
doigt hein donc là pour le coup c'est
pas de plein droit c'est une possibilité
euh la la question qui se
pose c'est les personnes qui demandent
l'asile dans notre pays est-ce qu'il
vaut mieux
qu'il vivent de l'aide sociale comme l'a
dit Monsieur brossa en l'occurrence 360
€
Lada vont dans ce qu'on appelle la DNA
c'estàdire le logement
d'urgence plutôt que de pouvoir vivre du
fruit de leur travail légalement payant
des cotisations sans que cela n'ouvre en
aucun cas le droit en aucun cas le droit
à une régularisation quelconque en aucun
cas le droit c'est ce que nous faisons
déjà pour tous ceux qui ont pass au
moins 6 mois sur le territoire national
et c'est ce qui se passe en Allemagne
par exemple en Allemagne on a la
possibilité pendant qu'on est en demande
de d'asile et même l'Allemagne pousse le
bouchon jusqu'à demande de titre de
séjour d'avoir ce qu'on appelle une
tolérance et de pouvoir travailler ce
qui n'ouvre pas le droit d'utiliser cet
argument pour être
régularisé alors il y a la question
évidemment de quelles personnes peuvent
bénéficier de ce dispositif en effet
nous avons considéré c'est le cas
d'étude d'impact qu'au-dessus de 50 % de
protection mais on pourrait
imaginer modifier l'article 3 imaginez
que 70 % 80 % aujourd'hui les Afghans
c'est à peu près 80 % ce dispositif
s'applique et puis a des nationalités
dont on sait qu'on va pas leur donner en
effet l'asile là on se doute que c'est
sans doute une manœuvre un peu dilatoire
et de ne pas l'appliquer puisque ça va
de paire avec la réforme de l'asile
qu'on va étudier pas cette nuit monsieur
le Président mais dans quelques heures
j'espère donc en fait ce dispositif il
n'est pas une mesure d'attractivité ou
pas une mesure d'attractivité les pays
autour de nous le font il ne il n'est
pas en lien direct évidemment avec le
statut de l'asile ça n'a rien à voir
évidemment qu'on vérifier l'identité la
question qui se pose c'est est-ce que
ces gens qui sont sur notre sol puisque
personne ici veut refuser le droit
d'asile est-ce que ils vivent de laada
360 € par mois et donc le logement payé
par l'État à travers l'association par
exemple où est-ce qu'ils peuvent
travailler par exemple moi j'ai des des
cas très que je vois passer par l'OF pr
de personnes qui ont des métiers par
tout ces personnes qu'on a sauvé pendant
la la mission harpagan c'est-à-dire tous
les les Afghans qui ont aidé l'ambassade
de France a été plusieurs milliers qu'on
a fait revenir pendant la la chute de
Kabou il y avait des traducteurs moi
j'en avais besoin dans les services de
police nationales il y avait des
médecins il y avait des infirmières il y
avait des il y avait des gens qui
avaient un métier des diplômes et qui
devaient évidemment pouvoir travailler
pourquoi le médecin l'infirmière le le
le le le traducteur il a fallu qu'il
attende 6 mois à 360 € 6 mois à 360 €
alors qu'il a tout quitté dans son pays
pour commencer à à mettre en place son
métier en France alors qu'il aura
l'asile bon bon donc je trouve que c'est
une situation qui n'a rien à voir avec
l'attractivité ou avec l'immigration
c'est savoir est-ce qu'on veut que les
gens travaillent du fruit de leur
travail ou pas voilà bon donc pour
répondre tout à fait à Monsieur
benaroche pour terminer je voudrais
qu'on se fâche pas entre nous puisque il
m'a parlé 2024 dernière fois mais
imaginons qu'il parle de 2023 je sais
pas si monsieur benaroche est pardon je
vous êtes voilà vous êtes caché au au
PLF 2023 monsieur bénaroche hors Ukraine
nous avons inscrit 320 millions d'euros
PLF sur laada et en exécution il reste
encore 2 mois euh nous allons exécuter
grosso modo 275 millions d'euros hors
Ukraine c'estàd qu'on va sousexécuter
c'estàd qu'on a en fait inscrit beaucoup
plus de crédit pourquoi bah parce qu'on
étudie beaucoup plus vite les demandes
d'asile ça veut pas dire qu'il y a moins
de demandeurs d'asile ça veut dire qu'on
étudie beaucoup plus vite parce que
quand vous avez arrêté d'avoir demande
d'asile et qu'on vous dit OUI ou qu'on
vous dit non bah vous ne touchez plus
laada voilà donc c'est normal donc nos
chiffres sont sincères notre stratégie
fonctionne vous imaginez monsieur baroch
ça a baissé alors même qu'on avit pas
encore la loi immigration vous imaginez
quand cette loi efficace sera votée à
quel point on pour être encore plus
efficace sur laad donc voilà cet article
4 n'est pas non plus une mesure
d'attractivité c'est une mesure où il
faut savoir ce qu'on ce qu'on veut
est-ce que les gens vivent de l'aide
sociale est-ce que les gens vivent du
fruit de leur travail bon voilà si
l'article 4 est supprimé ben il
continueront à vivre de l'aide sociale
c'est un peu dommage parce que c'est
moins de cotisation c'est moins de
rémunération c'est moins de G dans
logement d'urgence et ça ne veut pas
dire que pour autant on les régularisera
voilà merci monsieur le ministre je suis
saisi de quatre amendements identiques
de suppression de l'article 4
le l'amendement
656 est présenté par madame le
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président vous
l'avez tous compris l'amendement de
suppression que nous portons avec Madame
Jourda se situe dans le casadre de
l'accord qui est intervenu entre les
deux groupes de la majorité
sénatorial et et
et le contenu de cet accord que nous
vous présenterons dans quelques minutes
explique cette demande de retrait qui
n'est une ise pour personne le groupe
centriste n'était pas opposé à la mesure
proposée par le gouvernement mais depuis
le
début dit que elle doit être relativisée
et je voudrais simplement dire sur les
différents ban
que l'ampleur si je puis dire des
principes qui ont été mis en avant sur
ce
sujet est inversement proportionnel à
l'importance du sujet qu'est-ce que je
veux dire par là premier élément de
réponse qui sera assez facile sous forme
de pirouette politique historiquement
les demandeurs d'asile pouvaient
travailler dans notre pays cette
possibilité de travailler a été
supprimée par le gouvernement de Michel
Rocard à la suite d'un débat qui ne
change pas beaucoup qui était celui de
l'appel d'air et c'est pour mettre fin à
ce risque d'appel d'air que le
gouvernement de l'époque a mis fin à à
cette possibilité vous voyez qu'on est
dans un éternel recommencement je
pourrais également vous dire puisque
monsieur le ministre a cité l'exemple
allemand que nous avons pu voir dans la
presse ce matin que l'Allemagne était en
train de revoir sa position et de
retirer la possibilité professionnelle
pour une autre modalité ils imaginent
d'un système qui est d'ailleurs pas
totalement saut de travail d'utilité
collective maintenant pour regarder le
fond de notre sujet est-ce qu'il y a un
de réalité de notre part en vous
proposant cette suppression je ne crois
pas pour deux raisons la première c'est
que nous parlons d'un sujet qui est même
si sont des des personnes hein donc mais
qui est à la marge de la marge madame de
La Gonterie vous a dit quelques
centaines de personnes elle a
sous-estimé le sujet à notre
connaissance c'est en 2022 1150
demandeurs d'asile qui à l'issue à
l'issue
à l'issue je vous prends je prends des
chiffres volontairement plus favorable
au soutien dere position
1100 attendez madame
1150 personnes qui ont bénéficié de la
possibilité de travailler au bout des 6
mois donc nous sommes vous me
l'accorderez sur un sujet qui est quand
même très très limité deuxièmement si on
était dans le cadre de la protection à
50 % immédiatement ce nombre serait
encore plus limité pour une raison très
simple c'est que ce pourcentage de
protection que propose le gouvernement
pour des raisons que l'on comprend bien
permettre à quelqu'un dont on est à
priori sûr parce qu'il y a plus de 50 %
de production ou du moins il y a une
bonne probabilité qu'il soit fasse
l'objet d'une acceptation de cette
demande d'asile les pays à 50 % ça
n'existe pas 50 % c'est une fiction
arithmétique c'est-à-dire que dans la
réalité de la demande d'asile vous avez
des pays à très fort niveau de
protection type Afghanistan éitré Soudan
et vous avez des pays à très faible
niveau de protection type Tunisie
Sénégal Côte d'Ivoire et cetera donc les
50 % faciaux si je puis dire sont le
résultat de deux situations qui sont
extrêmes ce qui veut dire que
bénéficierait de la suggestion faite par
le gouvernement en fait les Afghans qui
ne sont pas les Afghans d'pagan qui sont
pas les Afghans traducteurs et médecins
mais les Afghans qui sont actuellement
en Irak ou ou au Pakistan les des
Soudanais des hitrens c'est-à-dire des
personnes qui n'ont pas de pratique de
Français qui sont donc très éloignés de
conditions
d'employabilité et imaginez qu'il
puissent être
immédiatement qu'il puisse être partant
du 19e 20e j'ai bien écouté ce que vous
avez dit
vous avez fait référence à des gens que
l'on avait qui étai qui ont fait l'objet
de mise à l'abri et qui est déjà
titulaire du droit d'asile donc vous
voyez bien qu'on est sur un autre sujet
donc pour revenir à un autre sujet la
réalité c'est que une infime partie de
personne pourrait être concerné par une
telle disposition donc je n'ai pas le
sentiment je n'ai pas le sentiment que
l'on crée une révolution juridique ou
politique en supprimant l'article 4 en
exécution d'un accord que nous vous
présenterons dans quelques secondes
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à Monsieur zurec pour la
présentation de l'amendement
127 merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues cet article 4 propose de
faciliter l'accès au marché du travail
au demandeurs d'asile originaire de pays
à haut tau de protection sans devoir
attendre la durée légale de 6 mois de
présence sur le territoire national pour
travailler ainsi une personne venue
d'Afghanistan ou de Syrie pourra
immédiatement travailler sur le
territoire national nous proposons
évidemment la suppression de cet article
en effet en laissant à l'autorité
administrative le soin de définir un
obscur tau de protection qui permettra à
des milliers de migrants à la solution
légale instable de travailler sur notre
sol cet article constitue de facto un
appel d'air je sais que vous aimez ce
mot à l'immigration massive et
irrégulière en premier lieu cet article
vient pervertir le dispositif de demande
d'asile déjà saturé en effet alors que
la France accueille un demi milillion de
demandeurs d'asile sur son sol et que
130000 demandes ont été recens en 2022
ce dispositif viendra accroître la
pression sur les administrations
chargées de l'asile et constituer un
signal désastreux auprès des migrants
cherchant à atteindre l'Europe ensuite
en permettant un demandeur d'asile dont
la situation légale n'est pas stabilisée
de travailler cet article va favoriser
l'implantation de migrants sur notre sol
avant même que la situation ne soit R ne
soit régularisée excusez-moi le
rassemblement national s'oppose donc à
une nouvelle facilité de l'accueil des
demandeurs d'asile qui renforcerait
l'attractivité de la France comme
destination privilégiée de la comme des
migrants alors que l'assimilation ne
fonctionne plus que les services
administratifs et sociaux en charge de
cet accueil sur nos territoire sont
saturé et que les Français sondage après
sondage demandent un arrêt de
l'immigration légale comme illégale je
vous remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Dufour l'amendement 365 est défendu et
enfin à Monsieur ravier pour
l'amendement
calmez-vous monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues l'article 3 est celui
qui a fait couler le plus d'ancre et de
salive mais parlons de cet article 4 qui
accélère l'entrée sur le marché des
demandeurs d'asile on ne parle même pas
des réfugiés quand vous savez que 60 %
des demandeurs d'asile sont déboûté
c'est en être dégoûté automatique vous
arrivez en France vous déposez votre
demande d'asile quelques jours plus tard
vous voilà au travail ces agents
économiques étrangers sont une obè pour
ne surtout rien changer il faut cesser
avec l'argument utilitariste le droit
d'asile n'a rien à voir avec
l'immigration économique monsieur
Darmanin un appelé à être gentil avec
les gentils et méchant avec les méchants
mais il faut sortir de cette vision
maniquenne en l'occurrence ici votre
texte considère que les gentils ce sont
ceux que vous pouvez payer pas cher
alors qu'ils sont probablement sur notre
sol dans une démarche de clandestinité
finalement vous tendez à supprimer les
frontière entre régularité et
irrégularité en ouvrant le marché du
travail à la terre entière vous répondez
ainsi Monsieur le Ministre à la demande
de l'extrême gauche qui en appelle au
droit au travail inconditionnel vous
vous apprêtez à ouvrir une boîte de
Pandore d'immigration en cascade ne
venez pas ensuite vous plaindre de la
prétendue fatalité de l'immigration
clandestine de l'embolie des tribunaux
administratif de ne pas réussir à tenir
le rythme de des expulsions et nous nous
retrouverons ici dans 18 mois pour
étudier la 31e loi sur l'immigration si
vous espérez séduire quelques chefs
d'entreprise avec cette vision
court-termiste je rappelle que c'est
leur compétitivité qui finira par être
impacté par la charge sociale entraînée
par le chômage des Français
l'immigration clandestine régularisé et
le regroupement familial qui vient avec
permettez-moi de citer l'actuel patron
du MDEF qui a firmé ce samedi 4 novembre
qu'il y a beaucoup de chômeurs dans
toutes les régions de France et que
notre première responsabilité c'est de
les ramener vers l'emploi alors mes
chers collègues je vous invite à rejeter
sans hésitation cette mesure piège et
hors sujet en votant cet amendement 531
rectifié merci là Monsieur le minist
j'ai compris que votre avis était
défavorable il est la parole est à
Madame de La Gonterie pour explication
de vote merci monsieur le Président
notre vote sera également défavorable
mais si comme j'ai j'ai donné le point
de vue de mon groupe tout à l'heure je
ne veux pas prolonger les débats mais
j'ai écouté attentivement les les les
explications du rapporteur de de
Philippe boncarè et j'ai senti comme une
soit une hésitation soit une
contradiction parce que de deux choses
l'une ou bien c'est trop c'est votre
position sur l'article 3 mais dire que
vous êtes opposé à l'article 4 parce que
c'est trop
peu je je ne comprends plus quel est le
fondement même de votre position donc ce
n'est pas non mais ce n'est pas ironique
de ma part parce que vous savez on ne
change pas j'espère toujours convaincre
je pense que étant donné l'enjeu
s'agissant de quelques centaines de
personnes vous pourriez réviser votre
point de vue il ne s'agit pas d'une
ouverture abrupte du marché du travail
comme je crois l' a dit un jour par
rapidité de formule Bruno retaillot donc
voilà on parle de quelques centaines de
personnes et les chiffres que j'ai donné
Philippe boncarer ce sont les vôtres
hein c'est dans l'exposé des motifs donc
ils sont forcément justes donc voilà je
je je vous je vous conjure de réfléchir
vous ne pouvez pas à la fois ne pas
vouloir quand c'est selon vous trop ne
pas vouloir non plus quand c'est trop
peu donc il ne faut pas supprimer cet
article
4 monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
demandé la parole je vous en
prie alors à titre d'explication d' puis
que comme les comme les trois
amendements sont tend à la suppression
je comprends que vous nous ayez pas
demandé notre avis sur les amendements
présentés par Monsieur Zurek et Monsieur
ravier ce sont des amendements de
suppression donc par définition nous ne
pouvions pas exprimer de point de vue
mais je préfère par avance anticiper sur
les observations qui ne seront prob qui
ne manqueront probablement pas en disant
que nous allons voter vous allez voter
par priorité sur l'amendement 656
présentés par vos rapporteurs et
uniquement sur ces amendements qui
feront tomber les amendements de
Monsieur ravier et de Monsieur zurec
vous n'aurez donc pas à voter sur des
amendements
conjoints
la parole est à Monsieur Masset pour
explication de
vote monsieur le merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers et
chers collègues d'abord un mot sur la
forme je veux saluer l'imagination et la
créativité légistique de nos
rapporteurs l'article 3 et 4 sont quasi
enterrés naissance donc de l'article 4
bis alors que nous disons si souvent
dans cet hémicycle enfin un peu moins
souvent moi je le découvre dans cette
hémicycle l'importance que nous
accordons à l'écriture la loi sa clarté
et sa
lisibilité je suis d'emblé mal à l'aise
avec les tours de pass-p qui nous sont
proposés surtout au regard de la
gravité des sujets traités et aussi de
certains mots ou phrases entendues
maintenant le
fond tout cela donne l'impression d'un
geste non assumé celui de la suppression
de l'article 3 dont vous reconnaissez
secrètement et finalement la nécessité
et les besoins auxquels il
répondait à lire le dispositif qui nous
est proposé il n'apporte finalement pas
grand-chose tant il fixe un nombre de
critères et de conditions d'appréciation
qui existe déjà et ne requier pas d'être
précisé dans la
loi maintenant j'attends de voir comment
nos préfecture puis les juridictions
administratives car il y aura un
foisonnement de contentieux et donc un
engorgement juridictionnel de voir
comment ces autorités apprécieront du
point de vue du droit des critères
juridiquement folkloriques tels que
l'intégration à la société française ou
à l'adhésion des modes de vie et aux
valeurs de
cellees-ci Bref
comme sur l'article 3 et parce que nous
sommes constants dans nos engagements et
que je suis aussi issu du monde
économique nous nous opposons à la
suppression de l'article
4 la parole est à monsieur le Président
retaillot
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre très rapidement les raisons
pour lesquelles nous sommes opposés
depuis le départ à cet article et nous
appuierons bien sûr la l'amendement de
suppression du rapporteur on n'est pas
on est bien d'accord l'enjeu ça n'est
pas le droit d'asile le droit d'asile
est sacré à condition que il ne soit pas
dévoyé on est sur autre chose on est sur
euh l'accès de ceux qui demandent le
droit d'asile au marché du travail or il
y a une directive européenne c'est la
directive accueil de 89 et cette
directive accueil fixe un délai maximal
pour euh l'accès au marché du travail ce
délai maximal est de 9 mois et donc dans
les les 27 pays européens il y a trois
groupes de pays il y a des groupes de
pays qui vont à l'accès maximal 9 mois
quelqu'un qui demande le droit d'asile
n'a pas le droit d'accéder au marché du
travail avant 9 mois il y a une
situation intermédiaire à 6 mois c'était
le cas de la France depuis quelques
années depuis notamment depuis 2018 une
loi donc sous un gouvernement Macron et
là on nous demande l'immédiateté de cet
accueil pourquoi est-ce que nous sommes
défavorables parce que nous pensons que
nous envoyons un signal trop favorable
qui sera interprété dans le monde entier
et nous voulons avoir une politique très
ferme pour l'immigration je vous
rappelle que 75 % des Français pensent
qu'il y a trop d'immigration et que
désormais ce qui est nouveau c'est que
les électeurs et les sympathisants de
gauche y compris de LFI une majorité
pense que aussi l'immigration est trop
nombreuse en France et bien ne donnons
pas de mauvais signal et parmi ces
signaux là il faut refuser il faut donc
accepter l'amendement pour refuser
l'article
mes chers collègues j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public sur ces quatre
amendements
identiques de la part du groupe
républicain du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain et du groupe
écologiste solidarité et
territoire
l'avis du Gouvernement est
défavorable le scrutin est
ouvert
madame la Présidente carer est-ce que
c'est
bon plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est
clos nombre de votants
345 suffrage exprimé 329 pour
191 contre
138 le Sénat a adopté ces qu amendements
de suppression l'article 4 est Suppr
et les amendements
tombent article additionnel après
l'article 4 je suis saisi d'un
amendement de la commission numéro 657
qui est présenté par monsieur le
rapporteur nous sommes là dans la
présentation qui vous a ailleurs déjà
été largement faite par le président
buffet des termes de l'accord au sein de
la majorité sénatori l'écriture que nous
vous proposons alors quelques
observations rapides premièrement nous
représentons nos concitoyens ils veulent
que nous prenions nos responsabilités
ils veulent un texte grâce à cet accord
le Sénat aura la
possibilité de voter un texte à l'issue
de ces débats deuxièmement nos
concitoyens nous demandent de démontrer
que nous sommes capables de surm nos
désaccords nous aurons apporté la preuve
que nous en étions capables à travers
l'accord qui est présenté
troisièmement hier
soir vous avez nous avons pris
connaissance d'un communiqué de presse
du président du groupe les républicains
Monsieur Bruno rotot se réjouissant que
son groupe aura la possibilité de voter
sur notre texte une heure après vous
avez eu un communiqué du président
Marseille du groupe Union centriste se
réjouissant du fait que nous aurons la
possibilité de nous aurons la
possibilité de voter sur un texte qui
reprend les idées les souhaits les
désidératat du groupe centriste et tout
à l'heure vous avez entendu en début
d'après-midi le ministre soffusquer
rapidement en disant mais mes chers amis
vous me dites tous que c'est votre texte
c'est moi qui ai travaillé ce sont mes
idées c'est ma c'est ma réflexion c'est
le texte du Gouvernement et c'est le
texte que je vous présente ce qui veut
dire vous voyez où je veux en venir que
quand un accord a trois paires que tous
ces pires sont satisfaits des termes de
cet accord c'est que
c'est que par définition l'accord est
euh solide quelques mots quant au
contenu de cet accord dont je maintiens
qu'il est solide au regard de nos regard
de nos
concitoyens le euh groupe centriste et
le gouvernement souhaitait qu'il y ait
une possibilité de régularisation dans
les métiers en tension vous avez avec
l'article 657 cette possibilité le
groupe les républicains ne vouleit pas
d'un titre de plein droit opposable il
n'y a pas de titre de plein droit c'est
au cas par cas de manière
discrétionnaire le groupe centriste
souhaitait régler de manière solide la
question de l'autorisation préalable de
l'employeur avec ce que l'on a appelé
l'accroche législative vous avez cette
accroche législative et la dispense de
l'autorisation de l'employeur le groupe
des républicain nous alerter sur le fait
qu'il y avait une attention apportée à
l'ordre public qu'il y avait une
attention apportter à la réalité de
l'activité professionnelle
allégué tous ces éléments figurent dans
les critères qui seront pris en compte
par les préfets vous avez donc une
solution qui répond bien aux
préoccupations monsieur le ministre a
regretté que le Parlement dans son rés
raonnement qui est bien sûr fort habile
que le Parlement en transférant la
décision cas par cas au préfet se
dessaisisse de la possibilité de fixer
lui-même les critères mais à partir du
moment où nous voulons justement qu'il y
ait un examen spécifique et qu'on puisse
aller vérifier la réalité du travail
allégué comprenez que ce ne peut pas
être les critères législatifs qui fixent
cela et qu'il fallait bien à cet égard
un titre qui soit étudié dans le cadre
de ce pouvoir discrtionnaire et vous
nous avez donné j'en a quasiment terminé
monsieur le ministre dans votre
présentation lundi un argument
supplémentaire en j'avoue en ce qui me
concerne ouvrant des horizons je n'avais
pas en tête le chiffre que vous avez
donné c'est-à-dire que au moins la
moitié des salariés étrangers dans notre
pays avaient comme employeurs eux-mêmes
un étranger je n'avais pas en tête cette
répartition des choses et effectivement
dans ces conditions je comprends quand
même que nos collègues et souhaité
vérifier la réalité des éléments à
travers cela vous comprendrez chers
collègues si je puis me permettre un
mauvais jeu de mot à cette heure-ci que
le texte é migré de l'article 3 à
l'article 4 bis cela ne me paraît pas un
très grand voyage nous ne devrions
perdre personne dans ce voyage et c'est
une belle promesse pour la suite du
texte merci monsieur le
rapporteur sur cet amendement
657 je suis saisi de 19 sous-amendements
le premier d'entre eux le 658 est
présenté par Madame de La
Gonterie mais il faut présenter votre
sous-amendement ma cher collègue et les
explications de vote se feront tout à
l'heure dans quelques dizaines de
minutes je j'entends monsieur le
Président mais si vous voulez comme on a
une communication de la droite à la
droite je pense pensa que pour
l'ensemble de l'hémicycle été utile
d'avoir une version complète de
l'histoire parce que on a eu un petit
peu comment dire l'élaboration
parlementaire raconter aux enfants de la
part de Monsieur
boncarer c'est pas exactement comme ça
que les choses se sont
passées alors première sous-amendement
vous voulez que je les fasse tous les un
à la suite c'est ça écoutez en tout cas
ceux que vous avez déposé
madame ensuite il y aura il y aura il y
aura la parole à à Monsieur benaroch et
ca enfin on que souhaitez-vous voilà non
on va le faire dans l'ordre alors vous
avez la parole sur le 658 très bien
alors
658 sachant que bien
évidemment l'amendement qui vous a été
présenté est une version
extraordinairement dégradée tant de
l'article 3 qui était le projet de loi
initiale que de la circulaire Vals ceci
est en posé nous avons donc déposé des
sous-amendements très rapidement ce
matin pour tenter de revenir à un
contexte un peu
plus sérieux et et en
l'occurrence nous avons souhaité que les
les comment dire le dispositif de
régularisation c'est l'amendement
658 soit placé correctement puisque
aujourd'hui il apparaît que la
circulaire Vals n n'est absolument pas
adapté le problème c'est qu' ce qu'on ne
sait pas monsieur le ministre c'est si
la circulaire Vals va continuer
d'exister la question se pose puisque le
texte qui sera sans doute voté tout à
l'heure ne vise que les métiers en
tension or la circulaire Vals concerne
toutes les activités professionnelles
donc voilà l'objet de l'amendement
merci l'amendement 674 est présenté par
Monsieur
benaroche Merci monsieur le Président
les travailleuses et les travailleurs
étrangers qui travaille sans titre de
séjour en France vivent dans la
précarité on on l'a expliqué on l'a dit
on l'a démontré c'est une une situation
t gens soit inacceptable dans un pays
comme le nôtre mais la situation est
même absurde puisque ces travailleuses
et travailleurs côtisent payent des
impôts sans avoir accès à leur droits
qui normalement devrai aller avec la
seule manière de permettre à ces
personnes de sortir de la précarité
c'est de les régulariser or la droite
sénatoriale vient de nous confirmer
qu'elle a proposé un dispositif qui est
différent de la régularisation puisque
les les exemptions et les barrières sont
multiples mais la régularisation n'est
apparemment pas un droit en lisant
l'amendement du rapporteur elle est une
mesure
exceptionnelle l'accès au droit ne
devrait pas être exceptionnel il devrait
aller de soi dans la même lignée
monsieur le ministre vous aviez proposé
seulement une expérimentation de la
régularisation jusqu'en 2026 mais
pourquoi faudrait-il expérimenter une
procédure qui a déjà fait ses preuves en
France il existe déjà la circulaire Vals
et la régularisation existe déjà dans
d'autres pays comme en Espagne ou
plusieurs voies de régularisation
coexiste même il faut être très clair
sur ce point nous avons suffisamment
d'expérience en la matière nous savons
comment faire nous n'avons pas besoin
d'e procédure expérimentale ou
exceptionnel nous avons besoin d'un
droit et d'un dispositif péren qui
travaille en France a le droit à un
titre de séjour c'est pourquoi notre
sousamendement propose de supprimer le
caractère exceptionnel de la
procédure le 659 est présenté
par sous amendement monsieur kerouche
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur juste une remarque à à la
façon dont vous avez présenté cet accord
politique à l'allégresse et à l'euphorie
qui était la vôtre on sent bien que cet
accord politique a été une joie pour la
plupart d'entre vous notamment pour le
groupe
centriste cette remarque est en faite
cette remarque est en faite ce
sous-amendement propose de supprimer les
restrictions selon lesquelles seuls les
étrangers qui exercent une activité
professionnels salariés peuvent être
régularisés en effet cette mention
exclut les travailleurs des plateformes
qui en droit français n'ont pas le
statut de salarié la non prise en compte
de ces travailleurs est une hypocrisie
nous semble-t-il dans la mesure où la
relation de travail entre les
entreprises des plateformes et les
travailleurs qui lui sont liés à toutes
les caractéristiques et nous le savons
tous d'une relation salariale
contrairement à ce qu'affirment ces
entreprises de plateforme qui se
présentent comme des intermédiaires
entre des prestataires et des clients
les travailleurs de ces plateforme loin
d'être des indépendants sont sous le
contrôle de l'entreprise via des
algorithmes et ces algorithmes fixent le
prix des courses déterminent les
horaires préférentiels organise les
conditions de travail au quotidien il y
a donc très souvent un lien de
subordination comme l'a rappelé
d'ailleurs la Cour de cassation enfin
l'exclusion des travailleurs des
plateformes du dispositif de
régularisation ne peut tenir lieu de
politique publique le gouvernement ne
peut se contenter de constater le
caractère irrégulier du séjour de ses
travailleurs et ne pas y apporter de
répones merci le 670 sousamendement 670
est présenté
par Madame
Gul oui le groupe écologiste solidarité
et territoire demande à ce qu'il y ait
un accès à la régularisation pour
l'ensemble des travailleurs et non pas
uniquement l'ensemble des travailleurs
salariés comprenez par là et ça rejoint
débat que nous avons déjà eu les
auto-entrepreneurs et les entrepreneurs
qui travaillent notamment dans toutes
ces entreprises de plateform et nous
savons qu'ils sont nombreux nous
demandons donc que l'accès à la la
régularisation soit fait pour tous les
travailleurs quelle que soit leur
situation salarié ou
entrepreneur merci le sous-amendement
660 est présenté par Madame
Rossel merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président de nouveau nouveau dénis de
réalité
on vous propose parce qu'on considère
que c'est évidemment totalement non
pertinent d'adosser le dispositif de
régularisation des travailleurs
étrangers sans papier à une liste de
métier en tension par ailleurs critères
qui n'existe pas dans l'actuel
circulaire Vals pourquoi je parle de
dénis de réalité bah aujourd'hui par
exemple le secteur hôtellerie
restauration n'est pas considéré comme
un métier intention et pourquoi il est
pas considéré comme comme un métier en
tension parce que ce sont déjà des
travailleurs sans papier qui occupent
les emplois donc forcément il y a pas de
tension puisqueil y a déjà des gens qui
travaillent c'est oui c'est ça ça doit
être l'appel d'air comme dit mon
collègue reméy Carn c'est surtout
bienvenue en absurdi et je le répète on
peut pas faire la loi en faisant
bienvenue en absurdi par ailleurs la
liste des métiers en tenstion est censé
être actualisé régulièrement elle l'a
été en 2008 puis en 2021 dites donc le
monde du travail a quand même un peu
changé en 13 ans hein et depuis avril
2021 rien alors Olivier du sopt qui
n'est pas là ce soir je crois avait
s'était engagé Olivier du sopt bah non
je crois pas ah oui non alors il n'est
pas là je crois il avait annoncé lancé
une concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux pour actualiser la liste de ses
métiers début
2023 je n'ai pas l'impression nous
n'avons pas trouvé l'information selon
laquelle cette liste de métiers aurait
été actualisé et les partenaires sociaux
que nous avons interrogés eux-mêmes
n'ont pas l'impression d'avoir été
concertés d'avoir vu une liste des
métiers c'est pour ça évidemment que
nous vous proposons ce ce
sous-amendement parce que c'est tout à
fait inacceptable de faire reposer la
régularisation d'étrangers de
travailleurs de personnes sans titre sur
un dispositif aussi
déficient merci le sous-amendement 672
est défendu par Monsieur présidentard
Merci monsieur le monsieur le Président
euh le gouvernement et la droational
veut
uniquement nous l'avons vu régulariser
des travailleuses et travailleurs qui
travaillent dans certains métiers en
tension pourrait donc obtenir un titre
de séjour la personne qui travaille dans
un métier qui figure sur une liste mais
qui hélas souffre de nombreux défauts
tout d'abord forcez de constater que
cette liste est actualisée que très
sporadiquement la dernière actualisation
date de 2021 celle d'avant de 2019 alors
que la situation sur le marché du
travail on sait très bien évolue
beaucoup plus vite si elle est actualisé
sa mise à jour se fait sans réelle
consultation des partenaires sociaux de
plus elle est incomplète sur cette liste
des métiers en tenstion de mon nombreux
métiers en tension manque ça a été
rappelé l'exemple le plus frappant est
notamment le le serveur de de café et
restaurant et on voit bien que ce métier
n ne fait ne figure pas dans cette dans
cette liste ce n'est donc pas moi qui le
dis mais c'est d'après le rapport qui a
été fait sur ce texte et ce rapport du
ministère du Travail cette liste
n'apparaît pas totalement représentatif
des tensions actuellement constatées sur
le marché du travail pour pouvons donc
prendre des décisions si importantes si
nous savons que l'outil de décision est
faussé et donc c'est pourquoi nous
demandons la suppression de cette liste
des métiers en
tension merci amendement ident on est
sur lebien
661 sur le l'amendement
661 défendu par Madame Lubin je vous en
prie ma cher collègue merci monsieur le
président nous nous contestons qu'au
détour de cet amendement les exigences
en matière d'activité professionnelle
dont l'étranger devra attester soit
rehaussé la circulaire Vals actuellement
impose à un étranger de justifier d'une
ancienneté de travail de 8 mois
consécutif sur les 24 derniers mois et
franchement un étranger qui travaille
est un étranger qui s'intègre dans ces
cas-là pourquoi lui demander j'ai envie
de dire des preuves d'amour
supplémentaires
donc nous nous demandons de rester à 8
mois et l'amendement 675 qui est un
identique par Monsieur
benaroche Merci monsieur le Président je
pense qu'il faut commencer par rappeler
la réalité de ce que vivent les
personnes dont nous parlons ce soir
c'est-à-dire les travailleuses et
travailleurs étrangers sans titre de
séjour les travailleurEs et travailleurs
étrangers sans titre de séjour sont
privés de l'essentiel de leur droit ça
concerne bien évidemment leur accès au
droits par exemple en matière
d'assurance maladie mais cela concerne
également par exemple leur protection
par le cte du travail sans protection
ces travailleuses et travailleurs
doivent accepter plus ou moins toutes
les conditions de travail aussi mauvaise
soit-ell et sans protection elles ne
peuvent pas se plaindre quand elles
deviennent victimes de mauvais
traitement de la part de leur employeur
or ces traitements sont malheureusement
fréquents entre autres l'employeur peut
refuser et refuse souvent de délivrer
une fiche de paix cela peut être un
moyen de pression pour l'employeur qui
promet de la donné par exemple si
l'employé accepte des heures
supplémentaires ou l'employeur qui veut
sanctionner l'employé décide de ne pas
donner de fiche de paix tout est
possible car l'employé n'a pas de voie
de recours mais que se passe-t-il si la
travailleuse ou le travailleur n'a pas
de fiche de paix et bien il lui est
extrêmement difficile de justifier qu'il
ou elle a réellement travaillé or c'est
bien ce qui est attendu de lui pour
prétendre à la régularisation qui n'est
possible qu'à l'issue d'une période d'un
certain nombre de mois travaillé au
départ ça devait être neu actuellement
c'est 8 et maintenant on en arrive à 12
monsieur le rapporteur c'est là où j'en
viens à votre amendement vous demandez
des justificatifs pour toute une année
sur une période de 12 mois donc la
personne doit montrer des bulletins de
salaire cela pourrait paraître adapté
mais pour bien de travailleur et des
travailleurs étrangers qui justement se
font exploiter par leur employeur parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de papier c'est
infaisable et c'est justement eux qu'il
faudrait d'ailleurs aider en priorité
c'est pourquoi nous demandons par le BIA
du présent amendement d'abaisser cette
limite à 8
mois merci on en passe au
sous-amendement 665
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre par ce sous-amendement nous
contestons le fait que la régularisation
des travailleurs étrangers sans papi
demeure tributaire de l'arbitraire
administratif euh le cas par cas que
revendiquent les auteurs de cet
amendement pour refuser la délivrance de
plein droit c'est surtout et en pratique
la règle de l'arbitraire le plus total
entre deux étrangers dans une situation
similaire l'un sera régularisé l'autre
pas c'est le cas au sein d'une même
préfecture mais aussi d'une préfecture à
l'autre avec des inégalités
territoriales évidentes la délivrance de
plein droit n'empêche pas par ailleurs
l'autorité administrative compétente de
vérifier que les conditions fixées par
la loi sont bien rempli par l'étranger
il est donc faux de prétendre que la
délivrance de plein droit hate tout
pouvoir d'appréciation dans la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
étrangers sans
titre
sur l'amendement
671 la parole est à Madame
Olivier l'amendement 659 nous avons eu
l'occasion de le dire représente un tour
de vis un durcissement du droit existant
c'est-à-dire la circulaire Vals hormis
les critères de métier et zone en
tension la réduction du dispositif au
seul salarié les mentions inacceptables
et flous relatives au mode de vie et à
la société l'amendement insiste
fortement sur la non
automaticité le principe est clair ce
sont les préfets qui décideront des
régularisations formellement ce pouvoir
discrétionnaire est mentionné à trois
reprises par son caractère exceptionnel
son caractère possible et son caractère
non opposable nous avons une opposition
de fond avec ce caractère
discrétionnaire pour ne pas dire
arbitraire la loi c'est la loi à partir
du moment où un travailleur étranger
remplit ses critères il devrait être
doté d'un titre de séjour et de travail
tout simplement mais au-delà même de
cette opposition de principe nous
trouvons que la rédaction actuelle avec
ses répétitions relatives au caractère
discrétionnaire représente un excès de
Zè cet amendement de bon sens propose
simplement de mentionner le caractère
arbitraire de votre dispositif deux fois
au lieu de trois cela ne nous paraît pas
déraisonnable merci le
673 Monsieur fernic Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE
chers
collègu monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
visiblement une mauvaise compréhension
de de qui mérite d'être régularisé vous
proposez de régulariser les
travailleuses et travailleurs je cite
temporaire cette proposition elle
témoigne d'une fausse interprétation de
la situation qui est très très loin de
la réalité pour vous apparemment les
personnes qui auraient besoin d'une
régularisation serait uniquement en
France pendant quelques mois avant de
repartir c'est comme s'ils étaient d'une
certaine façon vacances prolongé mais
mais la réalité est toute autre la
réalité c'est qu'une personne étrangère
peut se retrouver en France en situation
irrégulière parce que son titre de sé
jour n'a pas été prolongé imaginez
imaginez que vous êtes blessé lors d'une
guerre dans votre pays d'origine mais le
système de santé dans votre pays s'est
effondré heureusement vous obtenez un
titre de séjour pour raison médical qui
vous permet de vous faire soigner en
France mais une fois soigné votre pays
est toujours en guerre impossible d'
retourner or Votre titre de séjour n'est
pas renouvelé résultat vous êtes en
situation irrégulière en France mais
vous n'êtes nullement un travailleur
temporaire vous avez besoin d'un titre
de séjour protecteur qui vous accorde
des droits vous avez besoin de savoir
que vous pouvez rester en France c'est
ça a été soulevé à plusieurs reprises
une condition pour toute intégration
c'est pourquoi nous refusons votre
vision de travailleur temporaire à la
place nous souhaitons que toute
travailleuse et tout travailleur ait
accès à ses droits pour cela il faut que
la régularisation ouvre le droit un
titre de séjour pluriannuel et que ses
conditions d'obtention soient claires et
permettent la régularisation du
travail merci le
666 madame
Céné et donc notre groupe demande la
pluriannualité de du carartte de séjour
pourtant la motion travailleurs
temporaires alors nous rappelons ici
l'objectif de régularisation et chose
peu commune nous allons citer le
gouvernement au travers des déclarations
du ministre de l'Intérieur lors de la
discussion générale nous avons besoin
d'une avancée législative pour
régulariser des personnes qui
mériteraient de l'être quand l'employeur
s'y refuse la proposition des
rapporteurs bien éloigné de celle du
gouvernement est tout aussi éloigné de
la réalité notre groupe nous avons pu
l'exprimer est loin de penser théoriser
ou accepter une imigration utilitariste
nous sommes fermement opposés au
dispositifs de correction temporaire de
la pénurie de main-dœuvre et bien au
contraire nous défendons le droit des
travailleurs à vivre dans une plus
grande sécurité juridique et cette séc
urité juridique elle passe forcément par
une visibilité plus longue que une seule
année notez que cette pluriannualité
limite les sollicitations répétitives
des services préfectoraux déjà bien
surchargés dans la gestion des titres de
séjour aussi par cette par ce
soutamendement nous entendons renforcer
les droits que les odeurs de
l'amendement souhaitent faire bénéficier
aux travailleurs étrangers déjà sur
notre
sol merci le 668 par Monsieur Dosu vous
avez la parole chers
collègues merci monsieur le Président
non mais je voulais quand même souligner
le caractère un peu lunaire de la
situation on a eu un un président
retaillot qui nous a expliqué pendant
des mois puisque ce texte a été adopté
en commission il y a quelques mois
maintenant pendant des mois que tel
Atila l'article 3 disparaîtrait puis que
aucune trace de cet article 3 ne devait
repousser je cite même pas de nouvelle
rédaction sous un autre article c'était
une des conditions un fil
rouge et puis là nous sommes en train
d'étudier donc un article additionnel
après l'article 4 qui est une réécriture
de cet article
3 et puis
d'autres auteur de cette proposition de
loi de ce projet de loi ont raconé
beaucoup de choses aussi pendant ces
derniers mois dans les journaux le
ministre de l'intérieur par exemple dans
le
JDD nous a expliqué que le gouvernement
était attaché à des mesures de justice
envers ceux qui produisent dans notre
pays jamais posé de problème d'
publicique bon et ben notre groupe
préfère cette philosophie de justice
nous pensons que les conditions
législatives doivent se suffire à
elles-même tout l'équilibre du texte est
de permettre ses justices envers les
travailleurs ne dépendant plus de
l'application discrétionnaire des
préfets et donc de l'arbitraire
administratif et donc nous proposons de
revenir à ces critères de justice
c'est-à-dire d'enlever la non
opposabilité de cet article je vous
remercie
676 676 c'est
ça monsieur le ministre est-ce que vous
voulez présenter s'il vous plaît votre
sous-amendement
676 merci monsieur le Président je
donnerai donc mon avis sur les
sous-amendements des autres j'imagine
après la Commission en ce qui concerne
le sous-amendement du gouvernement il
s'agit de de rétablir un manque d'après
nous même si l'amendement a été
distribué
assez vite hier c'estàdire d'exclure des
périodes dei
régularisation les moments de travail
étudiant ou de travailleurs saisonniers
ce qui avait été prévu dans l'article
initial du gouvernement si on met dans
le temps qui est possible pour la
régularisation par les préfets si on
regarde l'article 4 B il devait être
adopté tel quel sans les sousamendement
notamment des des groupes de gauche
alors en fait vous allez régulariser
possiblement plus de monde puisque des
étud ud qui travaill ou les travailleurs
saisonniers c'est des dizaines de
milliers de personnes supplémentaires
donc je pense que la volonté de ceux qui
ont écrit cet amendement n'était pas
d'ouvrir davantage mais de de refermer
un peu et donc je pense que c'est
nécessaire en tout cas c'est comme ça
queavait imaginé le gouvernement dans
son article 3 initial merci monsieur le
ministre le 662 est
défendu madame lin je vous en prie merci
monsieur le
Président comme Monsieur le Ministre
finalement vient de le dire lui-même on
voit bien que dans C exer de réécriture
des articles 3 et 4 semble-t-il dans la
précipitation même si les tractations
durent quand même depuis un certain
temps dans cette réécriture probablement
que les auteurs sont parfois allés un
peu vite en besogne c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous demandons la suppression
en particulier de de l'alinéa 5 cet
alinéa fixe en fait un certain nombre de
critères que l'autorité administrative
devrait prendre en compte au moment de
l'examen donc de la demande de
régularisation pour motifs professionnel
or en fait ces critères sont déjà
aujourd'hui pris en compte par exemple
le critère de d'ordre publique qui est
pris en compte par l'article
l412-5 qui fixe une réserve générale
d'ordre publ et qui interdit donc la
délivrance déjà aujourd'hui hein d'un
titre de séjour lorsque la présence d'un
étranger en France constitue une menace
pour l'ordre publique donc on pourrait
finalement se dire simplement
queà une petite erreur que c'est pas
très grave de faire une
répétition dans un dans un article de
loi mais plus sérieusement le fait qu'on
répète cet argument là dans la ligée 5
pourrait nous conduire à à considérer
que la réserve d'ordre public finalement
n'est plus intégré dans les autres
examens de titre de séjour et alors ce
serait sans doute considéré comme plus
grave puisque je crois que personne ici
n'a véritablement envie que soit délivré
des titres de séjour à des personnes qui
en effet pourraient menacer l'ordre
public voilà donc il nous semble que cet
alinéa au-delà de sa redondance pose un
sérieux problème et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous proposons sa
suppression merci le sous-amendement
667 madame Vogel vous en prie pardon
excusez-moi merci monsieur le Président
alors vous avez ajouté dans l'article
dans l'amendement dont j'ai oublié le
numéro qui réécrit cette cet article le
fait que euh on devrait vérifier pour
pouvoir accorder l'autorisation de
travail le fait que
l'étranger l'intégration de l'étranger à
la société française et son adhésion au
mode de vie et aux valeurs de celle-ci
ainsi qu'au principe de la République
mentionné à l'article
l412-7 alors les les principes de la
République mentionnés à l'article l412-7
c'est facile il suffit d'aller lire
l'article
l412-7 mais alors les modes de vie et
les valeurs de la la société française
ça c'est plus difficile et comme moi je
sais pas exactement ce que c'est je suis
allé j'ai fait une recherche je sais pas
exactement de quoi vous parlez si vous
savez de quoi vous parlez moi je suis
allé faire une recherche sur Google pour
savoir ce que c'était les valeurs et les
modes de vie de la société française il
y a beaucoup de sources différentes
c'est au hasard fait la même chose une
enquête du CNRS de
2019 je vous en cite une partie les
Français veulent choisir leur manière de
vivre et cela se retrouve ouve dans tous
les domaines de la vie acceptation du
divorce de l'avortement de
l'homosexualité du suicide de
l'eutanasie autonomisation refus des
contraintes épanouissement personnel
chacun veut avoir son mot à dire
l'indice de libéralisme des meurs a
beaucoup augmenté en 40 ans la moyenne
de C indice allant de 1 à 10 est passée
de 4,3 à
6,4 la progression du libéralisme des
meurtres est évidente alors moi je veux
bien
mais je m'inquiète pour vous je
m'inquiète pour
vous le sous-amendement 663 pour le
groupe madame Lincel je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président comme je
l'indiquais tout à
l'heure encore une fois sans doute la
rédaction a été un peu rapide alors tout
à l'heure on avait une répétition qui
pouvait peut-être plutôt faire sourire
qu'inquiété encore que j'ai essayé de
démontrer pourquoi on pouvait également
s'en inquiéter là nous sommes sur une
autre type de redondance qui nous amène
à vouloir supprimer les alinéas 7 et 8
parce que
figurez-vous que depuis le début nous
sommes en train de parler pour les
articles feu les articles 3 et 4 et
l'actuel article 4 bis nous sommes en
train de parler d'un titre de séjour
pour motif professionnel et que donc un
un titre de séjour temporaire
conviendrait délivrer donc à des
personnes qui travaillent depuis un
certain temps sur certains métiers ou
dans certaines zones donc on parle bien
d'une activité professionnelle or ces
articles ces alinéas que nous proposons
de supprimer demande de conditionner la
délivrance d'un titre de sé jours pour
activité professionnelle à la
vérification de l'activité
professionnelle auprès de l'employeur
alors de deux choses l'une ou bien en
faisant cela on considère que l'autorité
qui a délivré le titre a mal fait son
travail puisque précisément le titre est
délivré parce que la personne exerce une
activité
professionnelle et je ne veux pas croire
que les rédacteurs de cet amendement
considèrent que l'autorité à laquelle
ils font plus confiance qu'à la loi
puisque je rappelle que nous sommes dans
le dans la situation d'un cas par cas
administratif et non plus d'un droit
opposable donc je ne veux pas croire que
les rédacteurs n'it pas confiance dans
cette autorité administrative donc si ça
n'est pas ça c'est donc autre chose ce
qui veut dire que finalement on se
retrouvait dans une situation où des
personnes se verraient régularisé pour
des questions d'activité professionnell
avec un donc un titre professionnel mais
ne pourrait pas exercer d'activité
professionnelle et ça je ne crois pas
que ce soit non plus l'intention de ceux
qu' on déposé cet amendement d'où notre
amendement de suppression des alinéas 7
et
8 merci le 669 madame mogel je vous en
prie merci monsieur le Président donc
dans la même ligne ce que vous proposez
avec ce nouvel article c'est que l'on
puisse donner des aut des titres de
séjour sans qu'il y ait forcément une
assation de travail qui qui aille avec
c'est retourné plus de 40 ans en arrière
quand on a justement créé ensemble un
titre de séjour qui donnait aussi le
droit à
travailler et le problème c'est que le
découplage du titre de séjour et de
l'autorisation de travail ça rend
complètement ineffectif le dispositif
voire complètement contreproductif déjà
ça amène à des délais et des procédures
en préfecture plus importants alors que
on avait compris que le texte du
Gouvernement de la commission c'était
plutôt de chercher à simplifier à
accélérer les procédures liées au droits
des
étrangers et une mesure de
régularisation doit être vu comme une
sécurisation juridique du travailleur
déjà hors sol donc afin de s'assurer
l'effectivité du DISP du dispositif et
du recours il faudrait que évidemment on
est au moins en une fois le titre de
séjour et l'autorisation de travail et
en réalité ce que ça veut dire c'est que
vous avez réintroduit parce que vous
nous dites depuis tout à l'heure bon
alors il y a un truc sur lequel on est
d'accord c'est que ce sera pas
l'employeur qui fera la demande ce sera
le salarié qui pourra la faire et on
aura pas le verrou de l'employeur en
réalité vous l'avez réintroduit après
donc c'est un verrou à postériori et
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire c'est qu'en
fait ce dispositif il va continuer à
concerner les travailleurs et les
travailleuses sans papier qui
travaillent globalement dans des
entreprises qui sont pas des entreprises
voyou ça c'est le résultat tous les
travailleurs sans papier qui travaillent
dans des entreprises de voyou qui ont
comme business model d'embaucher des S
papiers et de les exploiter et de les
laisser sans droit sans cotisation sans
salaire descent ceuxl ils vont pouvoir
rester sans papier en réalité c'est ça
votre
modèle merci le 664 qui le défend
monsieur kirou je vous en prie merci
monsieur le Président en droit il y a
deux adages latins qui sont connus qui
s'oppose le premier vous le connaissez
tous c'est Duralex CDE l'X la loi est
dure mais c'est la loi et c'est le parti
prix que vous avez pris avec ce texte du
moins la façon dont la majorité
sénatoriale l'a réécrit c'est le
principe de durcir au maximum les
conditions de la loi mais cet adage
s'oppose à un deuxème adage latin moins
connu
sumumjus suma injuria
justice extrême extrême
injustice parce que à force de durcir
les critères du droit vous faites en
sorte en récrivant ces articles 3 ces
articles 4 que la loi n'est plus
applicable parce qu'elle devient trop
dure et qu'elle contient en elle-même
une injustice et ce texte par votre
volonté par votre façon d'être
inflexible vous le rendez déjà
inapplicable et c'est exactement l'idée
que nous défendons aussi dans ce
sous-amendement parce que bien sûr on
nous dit encore une demande de rapport
mais en fait vous dégrader tellement les
conditions de ce qui était la circulaire
Vals qu'il nous semble évident que le
dispositif bricolé que vous nous
proposez doit être évalué dans les
délais les plus brefs et qu'il ne doit
être mis en place que pour une délée
expérimentale d'une
année mais merci nous en avons terminé
avec les 19 sous-amendements nous
poursuivons avec les amendements le
389 madame Vogel je vous en prie merci
monsieur le Président si ça vous va je
vais défendre tous les amendements à la
suite puisque les autres sont merci
parce que vous inquiétez pas je veux pas
parler pendant 8
minutes parce que non pas les 350 de
simplement les quat qui suivent puisque
ce sont des amendements replis
l'amendement 389 porte et je sais que
c'est difficile c'est difficile dans ce
débat là que nous avons depuis lundi et
ça devient aussi difficile dans le débat
public qui est le notre sur
l'immigration depuis des années cet
amendement il porte une chose très
simple c'est la régularisation de tous
les travailleurs sans papier
oui la régularisation de tous les
travailleurs sans papier et pas
seulement des travailleurs et des
travailleuses qui travaillent dans des
métiers en tenstion je vais vous donner
un exemple et vous le connaissez parce
que je pense qu'il a été euh débattu de
nombreuses fois dans les débats publics
c'est l'exemple du groupe de la poste je
sais pas si c'est un métier intention
monsieur le ministre la poste le groupe
La Poste emploie par le biais d'un
système opaque de sous-traitants des
centaines de travailleuses et de
travailleurs étrangers sans titre de
séjour et comme tous les travailleurs et
toutes les travailleuses du groupe ils
travaillent tôt le matin tard le soir
pendant la nuit pour trier les courriers
et pour livrer les colis qui sont livrés
à la poste en bas que nous recevons tous
les jours mais contrairement aux autres
leurs heures supplémentaires demeurent
impayé ils ont reçu comme consigne de se
caché dès que l'inspection du travail
arrive il travaillent sans être déclaré
il bénéficie ni de la sécurité sociale
ni des protections prévues par le COD de
travail par exemple en matière de
licenciement et généralement quand on
les vire c'est par SMS une telle
précarité la Poste La Poste le droit de
recevoir du courrier on reçoit des
courriers trop souvent on passe je sais
pas combien de courriers on reçoit tous
les jours on y est très attaché c'est
pas un un métier en tension est-ce que
vous pouvez accepter que toutes ces
travailleuses et tous ces travailleurs
demeurent
précarisé sans
droit sans protection social qui n'est
pas droit à la santé qui n'est pas droit
à la retraite alors qu'il travaille
depuis parfois des années pour nous
livrer notre courrier et donc nous on a
une approche pragmatique par rapport à
cette question la liste des métiers en
tension c'est une usine à gaz
par décret par région par secteur je
veux dire c'est super compliqué alors
qu'on sait très bien que tous les
travailleeurs et les trava qui
travaillent déjà ils sont déjà là ils
font un travail qui est nécessaire sinon
ils seraient pas là et le plus simple
c'est pas de se prendre la tête avec des
décrets chaque année très compliqués
c'est simplement de tous et toutes les
régulariser et là on aura les
cotisations qu'il faut pour les
retraites on aura plus de dumping social
et tout ira beaucoup mieux
merci Madame Vogel pour le le 170 est
défendu madame de La Gonterie madame de
La Gonterie et et les collègues du
groupe socialiste le 170 là il est
défendu il est
défendu le 461 pour Monsieur
Brossard défendu merci Monsieur brossa
le 200 nous avons nous avons trois
identiques le
239 madame de La Gonterie vous l'avez
pas vous est dans l'allas quand même est
dans l'allas il est dans l'allas
il ah oui je je vois que le dérouleur
mouline mais euh nous en sommes au 260
au 239 rectifiés qui est un identique
avec le 330 et le 370 sont les trois
derniers amendements
de la discussion ça ne vient toujours
pas
bon bien le 239 est défendu le 330
monsieur benaroche
oui monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement un peu de repli par rapport à
celui de de ma camarade Mélanie Vogel
parce qu'il se trouve que un certain
nombre de de parlementaires euh de
différents partis de l'Assemblée
nationale groupe d'assemblée nationale
et et du Sénat y compris d'ailleurs je
le signale le du groupe renaissance du
groupe modem et du groupe lot c'estàdire
des groupes centristes et et et et du
groupe majoritaire soutenant le
président de la République à l'Assemblée
nationale défendit des positions pour
essayer d'obtenir et de et d'avancer
dans un accord en faisant preuve
d'imagination celle dont le ministre a
m'a reproché de manquer pour notre
groupe pour trouver en fait des
alternatives et des solutions qui en
fait n'étaient pas des acccords pour
essayer euh de rendre tout à fait de
vider de son sens le projet de loi
initial de du gouvernement mais pour
essayer au contraire de trouver des
consensus pour le renforcer pour le
faire adopter bon la discussion monsieur
darmana vous dites souvent vous avez pas
vous avez pas discuté avec nous parce
que vous saviez qu'on refusait le texte
donc vous avez discuté avec la droite
bon qui de toute façon aurait refusé le
texte et qui le refuserait d'ailleurs
toujours si c'était le même que celui
que vous aviez proposé mais vous avez
préférer ce type d'accord et de
discussion plutôt que de continuer dans
le sens d'un d'un d'un accueil des
migrants d'une d'une intégration par le
travail et d'une
formation de ces personnes afin qu'elle
soit le mieux intégrée dans notre pays
donc cet amendement est comme je le
disais un peu un amendement de repli
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il propose des
conditions différentes euh qui
suppriment bien entendu qui reviennent à
ce que vous souhaaitiez au départ
l'automaticité euh le le non besoin de
demander un accord à l'employeur ni
avant ni après euh pour régulariser dans
des métiers ention et dans des zones que
nous aurions fixé les travailleurs
aujourd'hui sans papier en France donc
si vous êtes toujours à temps monsieur
darmanet de donner un avis favorable de
cet amendement et vous êtes toujours à
temps chers amis séndateur de de suivre
l'option qui a été proposée par un
certain nombre de députés de vos euh de
vos groupes respectifs du centre et du
centre gauche merci Monsieur benaroche
dernier amendement 370 présenté par
madame la Présidente carè merci monsieur
le Président sur les marchés dans le
bâtiment dans secteur agricole pour les
livraisons dans nos restaurants la liste
est encore longue mais voilà voilà
autant de secteurs qui vivent en partie
du travail clandestin depuis des années
cette clandestinité est condamnée sans
pour autant que nous puissions offrir de
solutions alternatives constructives
alors alors que constatons-nous d'un
côté de nombreux emplois peine à être
pourvu d'un autre de nombreux étrangers
en situation irrégulière attendent de
s'intégrer pleinement dans notre société
en pouvant exercer une activité
professionnelle en dehors de toute
clandestinité c'est une équation simple
à résoudre le gouvernement l'avait fait
en proposant un article 3 notre
législation est aujourd'hui dans une
forme de paradoxe le travail clandestin
est interdit et pourtant il existe en
dehors de tout contrôle les employés
comme des employés comme les employeurs
dans la sont placés dans la précarité
pardon en même temps les travailleurs
clandestins cherchent à pouvoir attester
de leur activité professionnelle pour
obtenir une régularisation même si nous
n'avons pas d'illusion sur le sort de
cet amendement nous proposons donc
d'aller plus loin en ne créant pas un
nouveau titre de séjour mais en
intégrant le nouveau mécanisme proche de
ce que souhaitait le gouvernement un
dispositif existant déjà celui du titre
de séjour salarié cela facilitera
efficacement la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier ce mécanisme
nous paraît plus adapté parce qu'il
s'intègre au droits existant tout en
répondant parfaitement un objectif que
nous souhaitons défendre l'intégration
par le travail merci madame la
Présidente avant de prendre les avis de
la commission et du gouvernement je vous
propose quelques minutes de suspension
physiologique et la séance sera reprise
à 23h45 dans sa
[Musique]
minutes
le
rapporteur madame le
rapporteur la séance est
reprise
nous allons entendre les avis de la
commission sur les sous-amendements
suivis des amendements la parole est à
madame le rapporteur merci monsieur le
Président si vous voulez bien mes chers
collègues les les amendements sont
extrêmement nombreux vous avez je pense
une idée notamment pour ceux qui ont
assisté à la Commission de l'avis qui va
être donné c'est pourquoi j'aimerais si
vous le voulez bien donner une
explication générale sur la position qui
est celle de de la Commission et de vos
rapporteurs vous nous avez beaucoupoché
de manquer de pragmatiste sur une
situation de fait qui est celle de la
réalité de d'étranger en situation de
travail irrégulière en France c'est
exact cette situation existe mais je
crois que le pragmatisme n'est pas une
politique on ne peut aborder la réalité
qu'au vu des principes qu'on a posé
auparavant et vous avez compris que ces
principes ne sont pas tout à fait ceux
que vous avez pu défendre hier au cours
du débat qui était celui notamment du
droit au séjour nous ne reconnaissons
pas le droit au séjour des des étrangers
en France nous souhaitons qu'il existe
une législation qui prévoit comment les
étrangers rentrent en France comment ils
y restent et quelle est
l'autorisation de travail qui peut leur
être donné dans la mesure où l'État
délivre et décide des conditions de
régularité des étrangers en France vous
comprenez bien que l'irrégularité de
leur présence ne peut pas créer un droit
à régularisation comme je l'ai entendu
aussi tout à l'heure l'irrégularité ne
peut pas être tolérée par principe mais
effectivement le pragmatisme que dont
vous vous revendiquez consiste à
reconnaître l'existence d'une situation
qui si elle ne peut être tolérée par
principe peut-être admise par exception
et c'est pourquoi l'admission
exceptionnelle a s jours a fait l'objet
de notre choix comme façon de résoudre
parfois cette réalité qui effectivement
serait insoluble sans ce principe pas de
droit à régularisation c'est pourquoi
nous avons rejeté l'article 3 mais une
admission exceptionnelle au séjour qui
est celle qui existe aujourd'hui une
fois que cette admission exceptionnelle
au séjour est reconnue dans quelles
conditions peut-elle re mise en œuvre
nous vous nous avez reproché d'avoir
encore durci les conditions de la
circuit harvals qui prévoyait comment
devait se décliner par les préfets cette
admission exceptionnelle au séjour vous
avez raison je ne peux pas vous dire
autre chose vous avez raison nous avons
durci les conditions d'application de
l'admission exceptionnelle au séjour car
tel est aussi notre notre conception des
choses encore une fois ce qui est
exceptionnel ne doit pas être facilité
et doit être correctementcadré c'est le
cas c'est le cas de ce que nous avons
fait dans les conditions qui vous ont
été énumérées tout à l'heure alors oui
une admission exceptionnelle parce que
irrégularité ne peut pas être un
principe et ne peut pas être créatrice
de droit oui une admission plus dure
parce qu'effectivement nous ne
souhaitons pas que la régularisation
soit simple et effectivement c'est dans
ces conditions que cet article est
présenté donc bien évidemment l'ensemble
des sous-amendements qui ne souhait pas
abonder en ce sens qui n'adhère pas à
cette vision des choses nous avons émis
un admi défavorable c'est-à-dire la
quasittalité des sous-amendements à
l'exception de l'amendement du
gouvernement numéro 676 pourquoi parce
que même si monsieur le ministre n'est
pas venu avec le texte qui ressortir à
d'ici il est entré je crois par ce
sous-amendement dans l'idée qui a été la
nôtre qui est de rendre plus restrictive
les conditions de l'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour et il a
effectivement déposé un amendement qui
les rend plus restrictive donc c'est un
avis favorable sur l'amendement 676 et
défavorable sur l'ensemble des autres
sous-amendements
monsieur le ministre quels sont les avis
du gouvernement sur ces sous-amendements
et et amendements et l'amendement aussi
évidemment le premier d'entre eu le 657
merci monsieur le Président je suis
largement exprimé sur le principe du 3
du 4 bis je vais parvenir en détail sur
ce point c'est un avis de de sagesse sur
l'amendement peut-être un point de de
précision pour Madame la rapporteur mais
aussi pour ceux qui sont intervenus dans
le débat et puis j'ai des positions
favorables sur un certain nombre de
sousamendement qui on ét déposé par
notamment le le groupe socialiste ou le
groupe vert voilà le le je voudrais ici
dire Madame la rapporteur mais ai je dis
aux autres sénateurs on on ne durcit pas
la circulaire Val avec le cbis on va
créer une autre
circulaire c'est important de
comprendre pour répondre la question à
Madame la gonri Vals va rester Vals si
j'ose dire voilà vous vous le connaissez
bien mieux que moi
[Musique]
bon et c'est une circulaire qui n'est
pas Conseil d'État opposable voilà et
donc là nous allons créer avec le 4 bis
aujourd'hui et puis modifier j'imagine
l'assemé nationale puis modifier en CMP
puis puis puis puis si nous gardons le
même principe une circulaire nouvelle on
l'appellera du sof on l'APPA comme vous
voulez on
l'appellera je sens que ça vous je sens
que ça
vous euh je vais arrêter là M mes
provocations sinon donc on nouvelle ire
qui permettra la régularisation de
personnes qui sont dans les métiers
entention c'est bien ce qui est marqué
dans dans ce texte et alors là je suis
d'accord avec vous je crois que il y a
un mieux on supprime l'employeur sur
l'employé mais il y a une réintroduction
de vérification à postériorie qui
mériterait sans doute d'être modifié je
suis pas sûr qu'on y arrivera
aujourd'hui mais on aura l'occasion d'en
parler rationnellement ave avec des
échanges qui nous intéresseront bien sûr
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça on va donc
créer une nouvelle circulaire dont
l'amendement prend bien soin de marquer
qu'il n'est pas opposable bon alors on
peut le garder parce que par principe
c'est ce que veut pas non plus le
ministère de l'intérieur mais ça me
parit superfettatoire mais on va pas
proposer un une suppression de de cette
de cette disposition je pense même
qu'elle at tirait trop l'œil d'ailleurs
de ceux qui voudraient le contester mais
je ferme la parenthèse en revanche c'est
bien une circulaire une autre circulaire
que celle de la circulaire Vals donc on
ne durcit pas Vals on fait une autre
circulaire dont les dispositions de
possibles régularisation sont plus
durcies que l'article 3 qui avait été
imaginé bien évidemment même si
l'article 3 avait été au cas par cas
parce qu'en fait il y a trois types
d'AES aujourd'hui il y a l'es Vals qu'on
connaît créé aussi par une mesure
législative il y a l'es compagnon
desmaus qui avait été imaginé par le
ministre Colomb qui qui fait que les
gens qui sont dans le parcours des Maus
peuvent être régularisés et puis il y a
une AES mineurs qui deviennent majeur
dans l'année de leur majorité on va dire
ça comme ça l'apprenti boulanger de de
17 ans et demi il est apprenti boulanger
il est aidé par le département il est
aidé par la République à 17 ans et demi
puis à 18 ans l'AINF env de partir bon
alors évidemment tout le monde écrit
pour dire c'est pas possible on aime
tous notre apprenti boulanger donc on a
créé disposition qui permet de dire bah
non il termine son année comme étant
régulier donc là on créit une 4è AES
c'est ce que nous faisons dans les
conditions que Madame la rapporteur a
précisé c'est important parce que j'ai
lu et relu que on durciss s Vals mais
n'est évidemment pas ce que nous
écrivons alors cependant monsieur le
Président je donne un avis favorable au
669 de Monsieur
benaroche
671 de Monsieur benaroche
665 de Madame de La Gonterie pardon si
ce'est pas ceux qui ont porté la voix
mais c'est ceux que j'ai dans mon dans
ma lias 675 monsieur benaroche et 671 de
Madame de la Conterie ça correspond en
fait à l'article 3 que vous reprenez
évidemment ici ou là par ce amendement
je n'ai pas cédé à la au durcissement ou
alors à l'ouverture plus grande
qu'aurait été l'article 3 profitant du C
bis je ne suis pas rentré dans dans ce
point de vue donc je donne un avis
défavorable à tous les autres évidemment
je je soutiens le sous amend du
gouvernement quels que soi les résultats
de de ces de ces votes de
sous-amendements je donnerai un avis de
sagesse en espérant qu'il soit
évidemment adopté l'article 4 b souhaité
par la majorité
sénatoriale merci merci Monsieur le
Ministre on va donc madame de La
Gonterie vous avez demandé la
parole non c'est un scrutin pi allez-y
c'est les deux monsieur le Président de
vote sur sousamendement 658 explication
de vote je vais vous faire un un grand
plaisir sur l'ensemble avec plaisir
madame de La Gonterie plaisir alors pour
mon groupe nous voterons contre
l'amendement 657 des rapporteurs nous
voterons pour l'ensemble des
sous-amendements qui ont été présentés
quels qu'en soit les auteurs à
l'exception du sous-amendement du
gouvernement euh un mot puisque je ne
reprendrai sans doute pas la parole sur
ce point tout à l'heure j'indiquais que
une version de l'histoire avait été
présenté que je qualifiais d'histoire
raconté aux enfants je crois que
personne n'est dupe il fallait
absolument conclure sur un accord
puisque monsieur reetaillot avait très
tôt indiqué que jamais il ne voterait
l'article 3 quel qu'en soit le contenu
d'ailleurs précisait madame Jorda
rapporteur il fallait donc se
débarrasser de l'article 3 pas de chance
le groupe centriste avait identifié
l'intérêt de cet article 3 comment faire
sachant que la majorité au Sénat
nécessite l'accord de ces deux groupes
donc vous vous êtes rencontré réuni
déjeuné dîner pris le té le café que
sais-je et idée de génie il a été décidé
de supprimer l'article 3 et ainsi de
satisfaire la demande de Monsieur
reetaillot de le réécrire ailleurs c'est
comme ça qui est arrivé l'article
additionnel aprè le le 4 et puis il
fallait quand même être un petit peu
strict donc vous avez allongé la durée
de travail nécessaire en passant de 8
mois à 12 mois vous avez remis
l'employeur avec une formulation euh qui
est assez alambiquée mais qui euh euh
anéanti la suppression justement ce qui
était l'intérêt de l'article 3 du
gouvernement
de la suppression de de de de la
contribution de l'employeur au
process et puis vous avez ajouté un
petit peu d'ordre public et cetera parce
que ça ne gâche jamais s'agissant de la
droite pour limiter un petit peu les
droits donc tout ça ass semble util mais
alors après vous avez un problème de
communication entre vous puisque chacun
dit que il a gagné et le gouvernement
aussi ce qui est absolument
rigoureusement impossible donc on verra
qui sortira gagnant à l'extérieur
monsieur reetaillot a dég est le premier
monsieur Marseille s'est dit quand même
non non non et puis monsieur Darmanin
dit ah bah c'est pas mal bon personne ne
lit la même chose dans ce que vous allez
voter en tout cas heureusement pour le
coup l'assemblée va faire le
travail merci madame de La Gonterie la
parole est à Monsieur ravier pour
explication de
vote je crois qu'on a besoin d'un
médecin du Galen peut-être euh oui
explication de vote monsieur le
président merci la gauche nous refuse le
droit de voir l'immigration partout mais
depuis deux articles elle nous explique
qu'il y a des immigrés partout dans
toutes nos cuisines nos champs nos
entreprises il y en a aussi beaucoup
dans les commissariats et et et dans les
prisons ça oublié de le dire et qu'il
faudrait donc régulariser sans quoi nous
serions dans un dénis de réalité et puis
pas seulement régulariser les
clandestins dans les métiers en tension
je crois que Madame Vogel a eu cette
sincérité et je vous en remercie que de
souhaiter la régularisation de tous les
clandestins il y en a jamais assez
toujours plus toujours plus cet
amendement de la droite sénatoriale
c'est en réalité la victoire de
l'article 3 de Monsieur Darmanin contre
l'article 3 de la Constitution article 3
de la Constitution je vous le rappelle
la souveraineté nationale appartient au
peuple qu'il exerce par ses
représentants par cet amendement vous
vous désaisissez mes chers collègues de
vos responsabilités de législateur en
laissant filer les régularisations
massives par voie réglementaire on nous
dit que ça sera du cas par cas on c'est
ce que ça veut dire du cas par cas 1 cas
+ un cas + 1 cas ce sera tous les cas
qui finiront par être tous régularisés
ça prendra sans doute un peu plus de
temps mais le résultat sera le même sauf
que vous aurez pris la précaution mes
chers collègues de droite de ne pas
emporter la responsabilité mais Infiné
ce sera la même chose alors il faut
savoir que la il faut savoir c'estes
régularisation massive oui ou
non j'ai j'ai j'ai ma petite idée donc
je rappelle quand même à la droite qu'il
y a d'autres voies de solution hausse
des salaires en réduisant l'écart entre
les salaires brut et net par la
réduction de 20 milliards annuels de
dépenses sociales non contributives le
RSA sous conditions système de formation
adaptée politique familiale et regain de
natalité merci monsieur le Président
merci merci Monsieur ravier la parole
est à Monsieur mon pour explication de
vote
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre et oui madame de La gonri
c'est un accord politique et un accord
politique c'est pas un gros mot et vous
l'avez moqué c'est un accord politique
qui révèle la solidité de la majorité
sénatoriale c'est peut-être qui vous
gêne c'est peut-être qui vous gêne c'est
un accord qui résulte d'un équilibre
d'une précaution je salue le le travail
des des rapporteurs d'une prudence aussi
et on a choisi le cas par cas plutôt que
la régularisation systématique bah ma
foi c'est un choix c'est mais en tous
les cas on a avancé on a progressé et
ces deux ces deux dispositions
s'ajoutent avec la circulaire Vals elle
ne se substitue pas ça n'est pas une
dégradation c'est un ajout et pour
reprendre une
on est un peu plus gentil avec les
gentils maintenant sur l'accord
politique bon vous allez tout même pas
nous donner des leçons en matière
d'accord politique parce que quand on a
signé l'accord politique de l'anupse
permettez-moi il y a plus de grand écart
qu' en a parmi nous désolé de vous dire
ça et ensuite le le principe de prudence
le principe de prudence moi je vous
trouve bien confiant par fois en vous
écoutant
oui on aborde ces questions un peu les
mains tremblantes parce que le choc
démographique il est là on n'est pas
dans les années 80 parfois en vous
écoutant je me disais ah ils ont envie
de ressortir les pancartes comme à la
belle époque touche pas à mon pote mais
on n plus à cette à ce moment-là mes
chers collègues et donc l'accord
politique que nous vous présentons et
cet amendement que nous allons à voter
et bien c'est un accord équilibré et
responsable je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
benaroche pour explication de
vote merci monsieur le
Président comme j'ai vu que ça vous a
fait plaisir je vais faire comme Madame
de La grterie je vais défendre et
expliquer le vote du groupe sur la
totalité des sous-amendements d'une
seule fois et en plus je ne reviendrai
pas sur le
mécanisme par lequel vous êtes arrivé à
fameux accord puisque Marie-Pierre de la
ganterie l'a démontré avec brio mais je
voudrais quand même revenir sur deux
points qui me paraissent quand même
assez dramatiqu voire même assez
inquiétant pour notre société pour les
années à venir en tout cas s'ils étaient
conservés euh dans le texte de loi
définitif qui sortira après le passage
de l'Assemblée nationale et après une
commission mixte paritaire le premier
c'est laame je v pas y revenir longement
on en a discuté hier je comprends
toujours pas la position du gouvernement
ni la vie de sagesse qui a été donné
après la démonstration brillante qui a
été fait par la ministre concernant le
fait que il était absolument improductif
et inhumain de supprimer laame mais j'y
reviens quand même parce que ça restera
un marqueur du texte qui sort du Sénat
la suppression de la me le deuxème c'est
ce vote aujourd'hui sur la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier alors
régularisation partielle importante
moins importante nous la voulions nous
ce qui nous concerne sans condition vous
la vouliez-vous monsieur le ministre
pour un certain nombre de métiers en
tenstion euh à la fois pour les
travailleurs pour les intégrer mais
aussi pour satisfaire un certain nombre
de demandes de l'activité économique de
notre pays et au final nous arrivons à
quoi nous arrivons que le gouvernement
lui par contre dans cet accord ce qui
est clair c'est un abandon total du
gouvernement sur ces deux point face à
la droite alors je dis face et je dis
abondant en fait il y avait vraiment un
affrontement je ne le pense pas ou bien
s'agit-il uniquement de tension
fratricide entre
des conception légèrement différente de
ce qu'il faut faire que qu est l'article
3 du gouvernement originel une
expérimentmentation de la régularisation
de certains travailleurs sur les zones
d'entention une automaticité législative
avec des critères définis de telle façon
ne pas défendre d'une d'une de politique
différente des préfets une absence
d'intervention de l'employeur pour ne
pas laisser les sans papi à la mercie
d'employeur à
délicat et c'est ce que vous appelz
monsieur darmanet le poids d'équilibre
du
texte il y a un certain nombre de
sous-amendements et je fais une
explication commune mes chers collègues
je laisse dépasser monsieur benaroche
comme j'ai d'ailleurs laissé dépasser
l'ensemble des orateurs qui sont
exprimés jusqu'à maintenant dans la
mesure où c'est une explication de vote
sur l'ensemble des sousamendements et
amendements qui vont suivre et donc j'en
appelle à quelques
tolérance qui nous permettra de d'avoir
un débat complet et éclairé de la Haute
Assemblée est-ce qu'on est d'accord
merci monsieur vous pouvez poursuivre je
vous remercie ces caractéristiques que
je viens dénoncer ça représenter pour le
gouvernement un point d'équilibre du
texte je vais encore reciter ce qui a
été dit par par notre ministre nous
avons besoin d'une avancée législative
pour régulariser des personne qui
mériteraiit de l'être quand l'employeur
s'y refuse je su et c'est il y a pas
longtemps c'était à la fin de la
discussion générale je suis prêt au
compromis et notamment à le compléter en
intégrant le critère de respect des
valeurs de la République c'est ce que
vous déclarez et que nous a proposé la
commission des lois face au texte
initial vous conservez l'aspect
expérimental bien
entendu le compromis annoncé par le
ministre sur le respect des valeurs et
de la République et des modes de vie ben
il est bien présent puisqu'il correspond
en fait absolument à la philosophie que
vous souhaitiez le pouvoir
discrétionnaire du préfet benah il est
revenu et puisque c'est des conditions
qui sont non opposables à l'autorité
administrative la faculté de
régularisation ne devient qu'une
possibilité puisque le doit se voir
délivré remplacé par le peut se voir
délivré et l'intervention de l'employeur
vous la remettez au cœur du dispositif à
postériori certes mais en tout cas point
critique pour la délivrance de
l'autorisation de travail donc au final
le point d'équilibre n'est pas atteint
le ni celui que nous avons essayé
d'impulser avec avec un certain nombre
de nos collègues du Sénat et de
l'Assemblée nationale ni celui que le
ministre disait souhaité ni même
d'ailleurs celui que le les centristes à
un moment donné souhaitaent euh essayer
de d'imposer ou en tout cas de négocier
avec la droite merci mon cher collègue
la parole est au président
retaillot oui quand quand j'entends
Olivier Hau ben je me retrouve moi dans
la majorité sénatoriale bravo Olivier
euh sur le coup de la
nuupes et ça nous a bien détendu à
minuit à minuit passé maintenant deux
observations deux observations la
première observation je crois qu'après
plusieurs heures de discussion il est
désormais bien clair que l'article va
cré l'amendement de Mir Jourda la
rapporteur n'a rien à voir avec
l'article 3 la preuve la preuve le
ministre était très défavorable avait un
amis avis défavorable sur la suppression
d'article 3 la preuve c'est vous mais
cher collègue de gauche qui l'a donné
puisque vous étiez farouchement accroché
farouchement accroché à la suppression
non contre la suppression d'article 3 et
là vous ne voulez surtout pas de
l'amendement de M Juda preuve que dans
les deux il y a bien une vraie
différence et puis faut lire aussi
dernier dernière preuve l'intervention
dans le Figaro de Monsieur Sacha Houlier
qui est l'homologue de François nëel
buffet à l'Assemblée nationale je je le
lis et je le cite à l'Assemblée nous
rétablirons le texte ambitieux de
l'exécutif tout le texte de l'exécutif
les choses sont très claires et pour
terminer deè observation nous avons
voulu par ce texte et par l'amendement
de Murel Jourda durcir oui les
conditions habituelles de la circulaire
Vals d'abord on proclame à nouveau par
rapport à l'article 3 qu'il n'y aura
jamais de droit automatique à la
régularisation et ensuite on durcit un
certain nombre de points qui sont très
clairs ça ne sera plus 8 mois sur 24
mois de travail ce sera 12 mois il y
aura une instruction un examen du préfet
à 360°gr sur l'ordre public mais aussi
sur le respect des principes
républicains il y aura aussi il y aura
aussi bien sûr c'est le salarié qui va
déclencher la procédure mais on a un
dispositif antifraude par rapport à
l'article 3 parce que dès lors que le le
salarié l'employé clandestin aura
déclenché la procédure le préfet va
vérifier factuellement
concrètement la réalité du travail en se
tournant vers l'employeur et j'espère
qu'il y aura des employeurs qui seront
punis mes chers collègues pour avoir
utilisé frauduleusement une main d'œuvre
voilà ce que je voulais dire et enfin il
y a bien sûr un délai c'est-à-dire qu'au
31 décembre 2026 l'expérimentation
sarrêtera merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre quelqu mot très
rapide parce que j'ai l'imession que
Bruno rotago a vraiment très envie de
dire qu'il est favorable à l'article de
régularisation dans sexe donc je le
remercie vraiment euh beaucoup euh vont
revenir à trois fois sur le sur le sujet
he monsieur le Président euh ce n'est
pas encore une fois euh un article
demain le C bis qui va durcir les
conditions de Vals je pense queon on
peut se dire les choses comme iles sont
il y aura une autre circulaire qui va
s'additionner à Vals et elle sera
différente mais elle ne dis rien du tout
puisque comme il y a rien c'est vrai que
le durcissement du rien est difficile il
y a une nouvelle circulaire avec des
conditions que vous avez fixé par
exemple exemple aujourd'hui une femme
qui n'a pas d'enfant et qui est
embauchée par un patron voyou que
celui-ci ne veut pas le
régulariser la la régulariser pardon
n'est pas régularisable dans aucune
condition sauf si elle a un enfant et
dans ces cas-là on peut la régulariser
au nom de Vals pas travail mais Vals
famille bon ce que nous faisons ça me
paraît assez logique on dit à cette dame
qu'on peut la régulariser imaginons que
le préfet aur aurait voulu la
régulariser parce qu'elle aurait aurait
constaté ce que vous évoquez voilà elle
il ne peut pas le faire en Val c'est la
loi l'interdit il ne peut le faire que
parce qu'elle a un enfant donc en fait
on encourage le fait d'avoir des enfants
pour être régularisés donc il fallait
bien c'est la démonstration et j'en suis
heureux qu'après de long longues
semaines de discussion par médias
interposé monsieur le Président on
arrive à cette évidence commune il faut
donc une disposition législative qui
crée une nouvelle circulaire puisque
c'est votre choix avec ce avec ce CAD
bis qui qui ne durcit rien du tout qui
fait un autre une autre circulaire donc
il y a la Vals qui ne bouge pas vous ne
durcissez rien du tout dans Vals vous ne
l'avez pas proposé vous créez une autre
circulaire selon les conditions du du 4
bis alors par ailleurs vous dites il
faut être très dur contre les patrons
voyou et j'espère qu'ils sonont
sanctionnés je vous encourage donc à
être cohérent et à voter l'article 8 que
vous avez supprimé en commission des
lois donc ça je prends de l'avance pour
le prochain débat parce que là on a des
sanctions financières extrêmement fortes
et malheureusement je le constate comme
vous les tribunaux judiciaires ne
condamnent pas beaucoup ces ces ces ces
personne alors même que nous faisons
beaucoup de procédures avec l'expression
du travail donc je pense que l'article 8
faudra qu'il soit qu'il soit rétabli et
donc je pense en effet qu'on peut
désormais si c'est possible voter dans 4
bis qui est donc un article de
régularisation et je m'en félicite on va
le faire très vite monsieur le ministre
non non mais on va quand même entendre
les explications de vot de Monsieur
dous et monsieur kerouche qui a demandé
la parole oui merci monsieur le
Président le ministre vous a bien
expliquer la façon dont vous vous êtes
fait un petit peu rouler tout de même
bon vous avez introduit dans ce texte
tout ce que vous aviez dans vos fonds de
tiroir à vous vous êtes allé aussi
pioché un peu dans les fonds de tiroir
du rassemblement national pour
introduire toute une galaxie de
dispositions toutes plus horrible les
unes que les autres et puis vous êtes
arrivé à ce compromis politique qui crée
un nouveau un une façon d'avoir un titre
de séjour une nouvelle façon de pour
l'étranger qui de se voir délivrer une
carte de séjour c'est le texte de votre
de votre amendement et donc tout de même
dans ce texte il y a une disposition qui
m'interroge sur la la vérification du
mode de vie je me demande quels sont les
moyens qui vont être déployés par
l'autorité compétente pour vérifier la
compatibilité du mode de vie
avec les valeurs de la République
et et les principes de la République
et comment on va vérifier ça sur quel
respect de la vie privée on va vérifier
ça avec quelle preuve matérielle quel
outil de surveillance
et puis comme ça n'est pas opposable on
va pouvoir raconter n'importe quoi et
raconter n'importe quoi on l'a déjà vu
au plus haut niveau de l'État quand un
ministre de l'Intérieur s'est pris s'en
est pris à un footballeur en racontant
n'importe quoi sur son mode de vie sur
la façon de l'étayer sur des complicités
possibles avec les Frères musulmans en
étant incapable de le prouver sur rien
et oui c'est c'est aussi c'est aussi ces
exemples qui viennent d'en haut qui
inspirent ce genre de texte et à la fin
on a l'arbitraire de l'État qui pourra
dire n'importe quoi sur les étrangers
puisque rien n'est opposable et donc
vous mettez à la mercie de l'arbitraire
administratif les étrangers en
France la parole est à Monsieur kerouche
pour explication de vote
oui merci monsieur le Président alors on
a on a eu 50 exlication d'un accord
politique cétait assez C c'était assz
c'était assez amusant alors autant
s'agissant de cette de cet accord
politique j'ai trouvé que le monsieur
monsieur bonne carère était plus dans
l'horison funèbre autant j'ai trouvé
Monsieur H relativement frétillant dans
la brosse à reluire ça je dois je dois
l'avouer avec un certain humour
également parce que que quand on parle
de main tremblante alors qu'on vient de
détruire un texte au marteau j'ai trouvé
que ça relevait effectivement d'un
certain sens de de l'humour une fois que
une fois qu'on a dit ça ce texte
s'appelle immigration et intégration et
il porte aussi sur il porte aussi sur le
destin des des étrangers et pour revenir
à des choses plus factuel il y a
justement une note qui a été publiée par
Linse le 30 mars dernier qui s'app l'
immigré et descendant d'immigré en en
France et juste vous en livreer la
substance parce qu'elle contraste
fortement avec tout ce dont on discute
aujourd'hui non non non c'est une note
de lin c'est une note de Linc ça
s'appelle vous savez c'est c'est
l'organisme qui fait des savez ce que
c'est voilà donc
euh c'est ça euh donc après on peut
contester bien entendu je sais que c'est
l'habitude tous c tous les travaux qui
sont des travaux factuels mais ça
devient alors très compliqué et on on va
plutôt du côté des fantasmes de
l'extrême droite et donc ce texte nous
dit pas qu'il y a pas de difficulté
s'agissant de la population immigrée il
y a des problèmes de logement on parle
du taux de pauvreté monétaire on parle
des difficultés vis-à-vis du marché du
travail mais il y a un mais c'est que
dès qu'on s'intéresse aux descendants
d'immigrés globalement le diplôme de ces
enfants d'immigrés et leur répartition
par catégorie socio-pressionnelle est
très proche de la moyenne nationale que
un/ers des fils et des fils d'ouvriers
immigrés deviennent où exerce une
profession intermédiaire et que il y a
une nette ascension sociale qui se
double d'un brassage assez rapide plus
d'un descendant d'immigrés sur deux à un
parent non immigré la mixidée des unions
augmente au fil des générations et en
matière religieuse induit une dynamique
de sécularisation les 2 tiers des
descendants d'immigrés vivent avec une
personne sans ascendance migratoire et
90 % des descendants adultes de la 3e
génération sont d'ascendance européenne
on est donc très loin de lavasion il y a
des catastrophes dans l'intégration
qu'il faut combattre B et c'est ce que
nous faisons collectivement mais et
c'est ce qu'il faut retenir et que vous
ne voulez pas voir c'est que la tendance
générale est encourageante et vous la
niz à travers toutes les caricatures que
vous avez
exposé merci mes chers collègues je mets
au vote le sous-amendement 658 avec un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
674 avec avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement même vote
même vote le 659 avis défavorable avis
défavorable même vote le 670 même
vote le 660 même
vote le
672 même vote le 661 avec avis
défavorable de la commission et avis
favorable du
Gouvernement même
vote non alors on passe au voix qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 675 avec avis favorable du
Gouvernement et défavorable la
commission même
vote le 665 mêmes avis même vote le 671
mêmes avis même
vote nous en venons au 673 avec avis
défavorable de la commission avis
défavorable du
gouvernement alors on va passer au voix
madame la
Présidente qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 666
même
vote
le 668 même
vote nous en arrivons à l'amendement du
Gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la
commission qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il est
adopté le sous-amendement 662 avec avis
défavorable de la commission et
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
il est pas on
plus voilà il il est sur le dérouleur
numérique donc 662 qui est
pour tout en haut madame de La Gonterie
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 667 même vote le 663 même
vote le 669 a reçu un avis défavorable
de la commission et un avis favorable de
gouvernement même même
vote le 664 avec double avis défavorable
de la commission du
gouvernement même vote très bien nous en
avons fini avec les sous-amendements et
nous en revenons maintenant avec
un vote sur l'amendement
657 pour lesquels j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public de la part du
groupe républicain et du de la part du
groupe socialiste écologique et
républicain l'avis de la l'avis du
Gouvernement sur cet amendement est un
avis de
sagesse
657 l'amendement ainsi
sous-amendé le scrutin est
ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est
clos votant 345 exprimé 345 pour 226
contre 119 le Sénat a
adopté
l'ensemble des autres amendements tombe
mes chers collègues la séance a été
ouverte par la Conférence des Présidents
pour la nuit je pense que nous pouvons
aller jusqu'à
2h on
continue article additionnel après
l'article 4 je suis saisi de quatre
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le
468 est présenté par Madame
alors depuis tout à l'heure on a parlé
de beaucoup de
personnes qui est bah qui travaillit
sans papier bien
entendu sauf que à force d'entendre
parler qu'il y a des gens qui
travaillent partout et que personne se
rend compte qu'ils ont pas de papier je
pense que ça serait bien que on puisse
avoir un rapport ce rapport sur
l'octroit des titres de séjour des
métiers en tension son application et
ses limites mais également qui
s'attachera également à mesurer l'impact
des régularisations sur les secteurs
économique concerné je pense que ce
rapport est vraiment primordial il nous
semble essentiel de prendre la mesure de
ce qu'il représente dans notre pays il
nous nous est essentiel de mesurer ce
qu'il apporte à notre économie
merci la parole pour présenter le
222 est à Madame de la Gonterie madame
madame narassig
oui merci monsieur le
Président il s'agit de d'un article qui
vise à garantir que la liste des métiers
en tension soit actualisée chaque année
alors tout à l'heure ma collègue Colomb
brussell a a déjà expliqué pourquoi nous
avions des problèmes avec cette question
des métiers en tension puisqu'il y a
quand même une hypocrisie majeure dans
leur dans leur définition mais quoi
qu'il en soit puisque notre sous
amendement n'a pas été adopté euh il
faut bien
euh maintenant s'assurer que au moins
cette liste de métiers en tension soit
actualisée et qu'elle puisse être
garantir dans la loi qu'elle soit
actualisée chaque année à à l'initiative
de l'autorité administrative ou sur
demande des organisations syndicales
représentatives puisque le marché la
situation du marché de l'emploi peut
évoluer rapidement euh et pour rappel
pourquoi est-ce que on veut inscrire
cela dans la loi la liste actuelle
remonte à déjà avril 2021 elle n'avait
pas été actualisée avant ça depuis 2008
euh et en novembre 2022 monsieur dusopt
qui visiblement va avoir une nouvelle
circulaire à son nom euh avait annoncé
lancé une concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux pour actualiser la
liste de ses métiers début 2023 nous
sommes en novembre et jusqu'à preuve du
contraire nous sommes toujours sous le
régime de la liste d'avril 2021 euh et
donc on a une liste aujourd'hui
déconnecté de la réalité du marché de
l'emploi et on veut baser donc un
mécanisme défaillant euh sur donc faire
reposer la régularisation des
travailleurs sur un mécanisme
défaillant merci pour le 476 la parole
est à Monsieur Beitz merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues par cet amendement il s'agit
également donc de prévoir
l'annualisation de l'actualisation de la
liste des métés en tension et de
répondre à la fois à l'invitation qui
était faite par le Conseil d'État de
cibler le niveau le nouveau dispositif
qui était prévu sur les métiers zones
géographiques en tension euh et de
prévoir une une remise à jour régulière
donc de leur de leur liste le
gouvernement ayant déjà exprimé sa
volonté de procéder à cette
actualisation annuelle il s'agit ici de
la concrétiser je vous
remercie le
383 est présenté madame
Vogel il est défendu quel sont les avis
de la commission madame le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
il est vrai que le sujet qui est abordé
par ces amendements qui est la
réactualisation des listes des métiers
ention est un vrai sujet si nous voulons
que un dispositif quel qu'il soit soit
opérationnel l'amendement qui a attiré
et retenu l'attention de la Commission
et l'amendement numéro 476 présenté par
Monsieur Beitz qui nous semblait celui
qui était le plus adapté au regard de
cet objectif de réactualisation c'est
donc un avis favorable pour l'amendement
476 et un avis défavorable pour
l'ensemble des autres
amendements
merci même avis du
gouvernement donc là
c'est alors sur je je mets au voix
l'amendement 468 avec avis défavorable
de la commission et du gouvernement qui
est
pour qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
la amendement 222 avec avis défavorable
de la commission et du
gouvernement même vote même
vote
l'amendement
476 avec avis favorable de la commission
et avis favorable du gouvernement qui
est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté et
393 tombe par
conséquent article additionnel après
l'article
4 c'est un un amendement de
427 présenté par Madame bogel vous avez
la parole cher collègue merci monsieur
le Président alors cet amendement il est
là pour résoudre une situation qui est
une situation de fait et je sais que
monsieur le ministre en a bien
conscience et que au fond l'article 3
avait comme ambition de participer à
résoudre une partie du problème il y a
quelques milliers de personnes en France
qui ne sont ni
régularisables ni expulsables c'est le
cas par exemple de d'étudiantes afghanes
qui sont venu en France qui se sont
retrouvé ensuite sans titre de séjour
parce qu'il a pas été renouvelé qui à
l'époque n'ont pas eu accès à un titre
de séjour et puis elles ont eu une oktf
et puis on peut pas les renvoyer en
Afghanistan parce qu'en ce moment c'est
pas possible de renvoyer des gens en
Afghanistan et ça peut durer comme ça
très très longtemps c'est pas beaucoup
de personnes mais c'est un nombre de
personnes qui sont dans un Limbo
juridique puisqu'on ne peut strictement
rien faire on ne peut pas les
régulariser on ne peut pas les expulser
aujourd'hui la France a une position qui
est en partie irrationnel c'est-à-dire
qu'on les maintient dans la
clandestinité alors qu'on sait très bien
qu'on ne peut pas on ne peut pas les
expulser et en même temps on ne veut pas
les régulariser il y a d'autres pays qui
ont alors je sais que Madame Jourda nous
accuser de d'être pragmatique bon moi
c'est c'est une valeur à laquelle je
peux me reconnaître il y a des pays qui
européens qui ont qui ont décidé d'avoir
une approche pragmatique et dire bon ben
ces gens-là on peut pas les expulser on
peut pas les régulariser on va faire un
moyen de les tolérer sur le territoire
de leur donner accès au marché du
travail c'est le cas en Allemagne et
dans d'autres pays et donc l'objet de
cet amendement c'est de créer un titre
de séjour pour ces personnes-là et la
raison pour laquelle on le dépose aussi
c'est parce que j'aimerais bien avoir
l'avis du Gouvernement sur cette
question qui est une question je crois
voilà il faut chers collègues être
honnête il y a des personnes dans cette
situation qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
elle merci quel est l'avis de la
commission madame le rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président je voulais dire à
Madame Vogel que je ne repose reproche
pas d'être pragmatique je dis juste que
quand on veut faire face à la réalité il
faut avoir des principes pour régler les
situations je pense que vous en avez
d'ailleurs nous n'avons pas forcément
les mêmes alors sur cette situation je
pense que précisément c'est le cas
typiquement dans lequel l'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour doit être mise
en œuvre pour des raisons humanitaires
ce qui est possible d'ors et déjà dans
le dans dans le czda et c'est pourquoi
je ne crois pas qu'il faille prendre une
disposition particulière j'entends bien
que vous demanderez la viis du
gouvernement aussi sur ce point mais
pour notre part l'avis était défavorable
du simple fait que la loi permet déjà de
régler ces difficultés qui je le
reconnais sont tout à fait réel merci
quel est l'avis du Gouvernement même
avis donc je mets au voix l'amendement
427 avec un avis défavorable de la
commission et défavorable du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui
est je reprends mes chers collègues qui
est
pour
qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté article additionnel après
l'article 4 deux amendements identiques
euh le prier le 224 est défendu par
Monsieur Durin merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement a pour objectif
de garantir que le demandeur pourra
prouver qu'il remplit les conditions
exigées conditions de durée de présence
en France et durée d'activité
professionnelle par tout moyen l'article
3 devait permettre et donc le nouvel
article à l'étranger de solliciter sa
régularisation sans être tributaire de
son employeur comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui nous l'avons dit la mise à
l'écart de l'employeur nous le répétons
dans la procédure de régularisation est
une avancée importante de la réforme
proposée mais évidemment il y a une
contrepartie c'est que cela rendra
nécessairement plus complexe le
rassemblement de preuves attestant de la
réalité de l'emploi et de sa durée c'est
la raison pour laquelle il est
indispensable de prévoir que ces preuves
pourront être établis par tout moyen
concrètement ça signifiera que le décret
au Conseil d'État qui fixera les
modalités d'application de cet article
ne pourra pas établir une liste de
documents autorisés c'est une garantie
mentionnée d'ailleurs dans dans l'étude
d'impact qui indique que l'étranger
pourra attester par tout moyen qu'il
remplit les conditions de durée de
présence et d'activité professionnelle
qui sont exigé pour la délivrance du
titre de séjour métier enttention
formalisons-le dans la loi merci chers
collègues l'amendement 470 est présenté
par Mame magrum oui tout à l'heure on
parlait justement de la circulaire
vs cet amendement il vise simplement à
se prononcer sur la fin du lien de
subordination entre l'employeur et
l'employer pour une admission
exceptionnelle au séjour et au travail
en effet la circulaire Vals oblige le
dépôt par l'employeur d'un serfant signé
à la préfecture pour engager les
démarches de
régularisation sauf que certains
employeurs ils font le chantage au SERFA
ou refusent tout simplement de les
signer donc ça il faut quand même le
savoir qu'on a quand même ses employeurs
employeurs un peu voyou qui quelque ça
les arrange bien d'avoir des salariés à
moindre prix et justement il jouent sur
le fait que s'ils ont pas envie de
signer ce serpent il ne le signe pas et
je vais vous prendre actuellement le cas
de l'entreprise rhtt c'est une
entreprise d'intérim située dans le 10e
arrondissement de Paris et en scène
etmarne pour laquelle les salariés sont
en grève depis depuis 3 semaines pour
obtenir ce document qui pourrait leur
permettre d'obtenir un titre de séjours
voilà l'absurdité de la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui celle
d'un système qui fait le jeu de certains
patrons qui eux ne jouent pas
correctement leur travail qui
s'accommode bien du travail non déclaré
à des tarifs inférieur au minimum légal
et sans payer les cotisations sociales
voilà la réalité du
terrain merci ma cher collègue madame le
rapporteur pour l'avis de la commission
merci monsieur le Président les
situations que vous évoquez ont été
réglé alors sans doute pas comme vous le
souhaitez mais ont été réglé dans
l'amendement de la commission qui a été
adopté tout à l'heure c'est donc un avis
défavorable aux solutions différentes
que vous pouvez
proposer monsieur le
ministre donc je mets au voix ces deux
amendements identiques avec un avis
défavorable de la commission et
défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adoptés l'amendement
262 n'est pas
soutenu
donc article additionnel après l'article
3 deux amendements identiques le
176 qui est
défendu par Monsieur Fagan
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues cet
amendement vise à octroyer des
protections supplémentaires aux
travailleurs sans titres qui
engageraient une démarche de
régularisation et le protégerait des
éventuelles mesures de rétorsion de son
employeur qui pour des raisons diverses
et variées euh et qui entretiendrait une
relation d'exploitant à exploiter même
si ce n'est pas la majorité des cas mais
ces situations peuvent exister pourrai
engager des mesures coercitives allant
jusqu'au licenciement du travailleur
sans titre et nous vous proposons au
travers de cet amendement que de pouvoir
octroyer le statut de salarié protégé
euh pour le travailleur sans titre le
temps de la durée de l'instruction de sa
demande de régularisation euh tout à
l'heure au travers de la suppression de
l'article 3 notre assemblée
malheureusement n'a pas reconnu celles
et ceux qui qui pourtant sont essentiels
à la croissance économique de notre pays
et de son pb mais qui demeureront pour
l'instant invisibles aux yeux de la
République faisons en sorte de leur
octroyer au moins cette protection
élémentaire en les protégeant de toute
mesure de rétorsion que pourrait engager
leur employeur dès lors qu'ils seraient
informés de leur démarche de
régularisation je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue pour le
439 la parole est à Madame
Margaté en effet notre amendement
également vise à protéger les
travailleurs sans papier qui
demanderaiit une régularisation pour
motif professionnels les protéger de ces
éventuelles mesures de rétorsion de la
part de l'employeur en effet un
employeur qui apprendrait la démarche de
régularisation engagé par son salarié
pourrait procéder à son licenciement son
licenciement par crainte d'une sanction
d'administration le monde du travail
n'est pas pavé de bonnes intentions et
le salariat se caractérise nous l'avons
déjà dit par un lien de subordination
entre l'employeur et l'employé et
certains ces employeurs qui salarient
des S papiers sont peu scrupuleux notre
amendement vise donc à éviter tout effet
pervers afin de tout mettre en œuvre
pour mettre fin aux situations de
clandestinité je vous remercie merci ma
cher collègue quel est l'avis de la
commission madame le rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président l'avis de la
commission est que ces amendements sont
fondés sur un dispositif qui a été
supprimé c'est donc un avis défavorable
et quel est l'avis du Gouvernement
monsieur le ministre un avis de
sagesse je mets donc au voix madame
kugerman pour explication de
vote merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
inévitablement ces amendements ayant été
rédigés il y a maintenant quelques jours
et dans un délai contraint au regard du
calendrier fixé par la Conférence des
Présidents ces amendements initialement
se rapporter à des articles supprimés et
réécrits donc bien év évidemment si nous
salions la possibilité ici de pouvoir
les défendre il me semble tout de même
voilà je ne fais pas je ne fais aucun
doute sur le sort qu'ils auront que l'on
ne peut pas simplement balayer cette
question là d'un simple revers de manche
en disant que bah finalement comme on a
écrit une partie du texte et qu'on peut
plus les raccrocher à l'article tel
qu'on l'écrit le problème n'existe pas
parce que vous savez parfois en écoutant
depuis tout à l'heure j'ai l'impression
qu'on revit
des grands débats philosophiques du 19e
siècle entre matérialiste et idéaliste
on peut vouloir rêver un monde se
l'imaginer mais il n'en demeure pas
moins que confronté au réel c'est tout
une toute autre réalité qui s'impose à
nous et et je veux reprendre ici
d'ailleurs ce que disait mon collègue
saintvoldelli tout à l'heure il y a
aujourd'hui une forme de conflit social
qui est complètement invisible et qui
pour autant existe donc moi j'entends
que vous dites madame la rapporteur je
crois très sincèrement que dans le cadre
de la navette et du travail qui je
l'espère sera en tout cas aussi
respectueux qu'il a lieu ici au Sénat et
donc qui devra se tenir à l'Assemblée
nationale cette question là sera tout de
même prise en compte parce que qu'on le
souhaite qu'on ne le souhaite pas ces
femmes et ces hommes existent ces
travailleurs sont parfois menacés et ne
servent finalement dans cette menace
personne et encourage un peu plus encore
acccord des employeurs et je l'ai déjà
dit précédemment loin de moi l'idée de
dire tous mais en tout cas des
employeurs qui ne jouent pas le
jeu merci madame la Présidente je mets
donc au voie les amendements identiques
176 et 439 avec un avis défavorable de
la commission et un avis de sagesse du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adopté article additionnel après
l'article 4 deux amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le
416 qui est défendu par Monsieur satarel
Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vais si
vous le permettez défendre à la fois le
616 et le
617 euh dans le débat qui qui nous anime
notre pays a aussi besoin de se projeter
notre pays a besoin d'organiser et de
maîtriser l'immigration économique
outre la question des stocks qui nous a
mobilisé avec l'article to et sur lequel
je ne reviendrai pas il convient de
traiter les flux cet amendement vise à
mettre en place une politique de
maîtrise des flux qui relèvera chaque
année du Parlement en effet avant le
premier novembre le Parlement devra
voter les prévisions du nombre de
travailleurs étrangers qui seront mis
l'année suivante afin de travailler dans
les domaines dit entention à la fois
métier et territoire le Parlement pourra
modifier si besoin par un nouveau vote
les prévisions votées en cas de
situation exceptionnelle afin que ces
prévisions correspondent réellement aux
besoins du pays ainsi cet amendement
vise à maîtriser les flux migratoires
économiques à venir il vient compléter
le Titre 1 qui a redonné des pouvoirs au
Parlement le deuxième amendement le 617
est en fait un amendement de repli qui
vise à ce que le gouvernement remette un
rapport au Parlement sur les prévisions
du nombre de travailleurs étrangers qui
seront admis l'année suivante je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue quel
est l'avis de la commission madame le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
euh la Commission a un avis à la fois
positif et défavorable pourquoi positif
parce que la Commission a eu exactement
la même idée que les cosignataires de de
cet amendement et notamment euh monsieur
sotarel puisque dans l'article 1er a du
texte que nous avons voté nous
préveillons effectivement qu'un vote
aura lieu tous les ans au Parlement qui
fixera pour une période triénal le
nombre de titres de séjour qui seront
délivrés notamment en matière économique
donc c'est une demande de retrait
puisque l'amendement me paraît satisfait
à des fois évidemment un avis
défavorable quant à la demande de
rapport j'ai bien saisi que c'était un
amendement de repli mais vous avez aussi
saisi que c'était une position de
principe de la commission des lois que
de ne jamais accepter donc c'est de la
même façon une demande de retrait ou un
avis défavorable monsieur le ministre
mêmes avis je monsieur sotarel je vous
en prie oui monsieur le le président
merci euh j'ai moi-même été surpris que
cet amendement soit placé à ce moment
dans la discussion et je pensais qu'il
aurait été mieux venu au moment de
l'examen de l'article 1er néanmoins il
il voulait apporter une réponse
spécifique sur l'immigration économique
euh avec une démarche qui était pas
exactement celle qui était proposée mais
au regard de ce qui a été adopté
surarticle 1 et des avis rendus par la
Commission et en particulier par son
rapporteur je propose de retirer ces
deux amendements et le deuxième nétant
effectiv il manque un amendement de
repli je vous remercie très bien ils
sont retirés article additionnel après
l'article 4 un amendement de Monsieur
533 de Monsieur ravier vous avez la
parole chers
collègues merci monsieur le Président
cet amendement propose une augmentation
substantielle des taxes sur l'embauche
des travailleurs étrangers cette mesure
permet de lutter contre la concurrence
déloyale des travailleurs étrangers ou
salariés détachés qui constitue une main
d'œuvre attractive pour les entreprises
françaises en raison notamment de leurs
exigences salariales moins élevées pour
rappel le taux de chômage incompressible
est estimé à 5 % au 2e trimestre 2023 le
chômage en France s'élève à 7,2 %. cette
taxe est une mesure de protection
sociale en direction des français mais
aussi des entrepreneurs qu en limitant
l'appel d'air migratoire elle limite la
charge sociale sur les salaires assumé
par les patrons et subis par les
salariés enfin pour ne pas aggraver le
cas des secteurs les plus en tension
notamment l'agriculture et la
viticulture l'amendement prévoit que les
emplois saisonniers ne soient pas
impactés par l'augmentation de cette
taxe à l'embauche des travailleurs
étrangers merci quelle est la position
de la Commission madame le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président la position
de la commission est défavorable car en
réalité nous ne sommes pas opposés à au
travail de d'étrangers qui sont en
situation régulièr car il y a des
situations régulières de travail
d'étrangers en France et il ne paraît
pas extrêmement cohérent de les rendre
plus difficil parfois même pour des
entreprises des PE des PME qui ont
recours à une main d'œuvre étrangère
d'une façon totalement régulière je
crois qu'il faut plutôt viser me
semble-t-il à encourager la régularité
du travail qu'elle a découragé avis
défavorable merci madame le rapporteur
monsieur le
ministre je mets au voix l'amendement
533 avec un avis défavorable de la
commission et un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté je suis saisi d'un amendement à
l'article pour un article additionnel
après l'article 4
575 qui qui est défendu par Monsieur
Klinger merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement a pour but de renforcer les
exence en matière de délivrance de
l'autorisation de travail nécessaire à
l'octroi du titre de séjour mention
salarié pour les étrangers souhaitant
travailler en France cette formulation
oblige désormais l'autorité
administrative à solliciter des
informations auprès d'autres organismes
pour mieux contrôler les demandes
d'autorisation de travail l'autorité
administrative s'assure d'un examen
complet et rigoureux de chaque demande
afin d'éviter les abus ou les fraudes
potentiells merci chers collègues quel
est l'avis de la commission madame le
rapporteur merci monsieur Président
c'est une une demande de retrait sinon
un avis défavorable pourquoi parce que
en
2022 il a été procédé à l'examen de près
de 240000 demandes d'autorisation ce qui
est extrêmement important et 4000
d'entre elles ont été refusés cette
année donc nous avons en réalité un
dispositif qui permet à l'administration
de se concentrer sur les dossiers sur
lesquels il peut y avoir une une
suspicion de fraude et il me semble
qu'il faut se contenter de ce dispositif
qui est tout de même relativement
efficace et qui ne crée pas une charge
pour l'administration qui soit
disproportionnée c'est donc demande de
retrait ou avis
défavorable merci madame le rapporteur
quel est l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur
le ministre même avis je mets au voix
l'amendement vous l'avez retiré merci
mon cher
collègue nous en arrivons à l'article 5
qui est un article supprimé avec trois
amendements de rétablissement
le premier étant proposé par le
gouvernement vous avez la parole
monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le président